Boom,
ladies and gentlemen,
Josh Barnett,
youngest,
average UFC heavyweight champion.
Now we're retired,
retired.
Just,
um,
I'm a free in the wind.
I'm like a Bald Eagle.
I'm just out there riding on that
freedom.
Just America.
The,
uh,
I decided to leave the fold of the UFC
and a chase,
my,
my own futures.
Um,
by my own hands.
Are you actively competing or going to
be actively competing?
There'll be some grappling stuff this
year,
but,
uh,
I'm figuring by the start of next year
I'll get back into the MMA circuits
mainly because it's just going to take
some time to set up camps,
managers,
the structure of everything.
I have a proper sparring partners and
all that.
And in the meantime,
we were talking about you're doing
commentary for new Japan pro wrestling
with Jim Ross and you do it on our
access TV,
right?
That's right.
Okay.
Every Friday night at eight,
uh,
you can see me sit down and run my mouth
about Raslan.
Yeah.
We just did a live show up at the cow
palace in San Francisco,
which they've been having sporadic a
wrestling events there,
but it was a,
it was a big draw in that building in
like the sixties and seventies I guess.
So it's a bit of a historical,
it feels like wrestling pro wrestlers
and make it a renaissance.
It's like making a return.
Yeah.
I think that um,
there is a certain audience of a certain
age gap that our age group that has come
into flourishing in,
in,
into the Internet and other ways to
which to go ahead and,
and,
and bring wrestling back up there and
show that wrestling,
whether it's the biggest company like
the wwe all the way to say,
you know,
number two,
it'd be new Japan.
And then there's all these independent
companies all over the place that uh,
some of them have quite a decent
following.
Billy Corgan from smashing pumpkins,
huge wrestling fan.
He owns what is the company that Nwa
national wrestling alliance.
Yeah.
So he owns Nwa,
Nwa,
the rap group.
It's that too.
You been.
That's what I hear when I hear Nwa.
I'm sure there's some attitude involved
with sure,
uh,
Nwa,
speak about the rest of it,
but uh,
um,
Nwa was his,
I guess it was a legendary sanctioning
body and so it wasn't any one particular
company,
but it was a,
a sanctioning body that would then
oversee certain titles and so if you're
going to be on this show at this time,
you're going to defend the Nwa
Championship.
The NWA commission would get involved
and,
and they had their specifications as to
how the title matches would be run and
whether or not you could lose by
disqualification or not.
Or if you go over the top rope would be
a dq and little stuff like that.
Killer.
Kowalski.
Russell for a killer.
I couldn't tell you.
Do you remember him?
I know the name,
but
I don't really.
I mean when I was a famous famous
trainer after the fact when I was in
high school,
probably Uwa guy.
It was an Nwa at.
Yes,
that's right.
Did we talk about that with billy?
I think we did.
He was like local cable when I was in
high school.
It was like three days.
Yeah,
like a claw.
He would like grab his own wrist,
grab your hat or like a guy fun eric.
Get his head.
He's got his hand up the claw.
It's like there's some nostalgia to it.
That's one of the reasons why I feel
like it's,
it's coming back.
It's like people who liked it as a kid
or now as adults going back to it as a
nostalgia,
the Internet,
it's,
it's much easier to go out there and put
product out.
Right?
So it makes it more easily disseminated
to any audience might want to see it.
Especially with like a,
um,
you know,
shows that are abroad,
like there's some shows that go on in
Germany and Austria that will get
streamed and people get ahold of them.
They get to watch them.
So it's not like the tape trading days
of the,
of yesteryear.
Does Jim Ross Hook you up with this
barbecue sauce?
You know,
he's got some fucking killer barbecue.
Scott.
He's got sauce,
he's got rubs.
He uses.
He's got all kinds of a minute.
A whole Menagerie of all your meat
fixings.
Is he a pitmaster one of those dudes?
Does he do the whole thing with the wood
and smoke with hickory chips and then
he's got his white oak on the side when
item guys,
maybe maybe he lost in my mind.
Yeah.
There's like two types of people that
use like that barbecue.
There's people like me that you pellet
grills,
which is infallible,
you know,
he's one of those triggers.
Sure.
It's easy for the pellets in it does all
the work for you,
but then there's a serious motherfuckers
chop wood and dry it out and they've got
the Coleman
are.
Those are the ones that start with a w,
uh,
the Weber grills that there's just
nothing to it other than.
Oh,
those are cattle grills.
Yeah.
Those are for amateurs.
Brow.
The real series dudes.
They get those side pick those side
smokers.
Oh sure.
You have the main chamber and then you
got a little wood box on the side where
the woods heating up and then the air
goes through and it smokes from this.
That's those people that cook and like
to 25.
They never let anything.
I throw stuff over over a gas flames.
That's my lead,
I,
I have no
business having any,
any voice in the realm of barbecuing,
but it seems like something you'd be
interested in.
I love it man.
Who into all things manly.
This is true and I like setting stuff on
fire and then eating it.
But do you still drive a manual
transmission all around Los Angeles,
which just drove one today?
Yeah Man,
I,
I've been driving around.
I just got it out of the shop a little
while ago.
My,
I have a 75 formula a firebird,
but instead of doing the ls swap,
which everybody does and I understand
why,
uh,
it's got a
4:55
pontiac in it that we bought.
I had a board 60 out.
It's got forged Pistons.
Uh,
I didn't go with forged rods.
I didn't need it I think because,
well no,
actually I did put fours rods and
Pistons,
but iron heads,
dual quads we look at,
at uh,
you know,
I don't know if the goal was to just
make maybe one horsepower per cubic inch
but have well over 500 pound feet of
torque.
That was the idea,
just and it's an automatic
unfortunately.
Yeah.
Senator Force with me and we'll gives me
crap about that all the time.
She's swapped out because I like just
being able to drive it.
Cut that third hole,
Sun third hole on the floor,
but the clutch pedal in there.
I'm,
I'm more than down.
But uh,
you know,
hell,
it needs paint.
It needs interior done.
So that's the Burt Reynolds car,
right?
Was that the,
you know,
that's [inaudible] 77.
Okay.
You're a 75 slash 75,
so it's got big,
big circular headlights,
a circular headlights still kind of a
square round off,
rounded off square for the center Jamie.
And pull it up.
We can pull up 75 firebird.
And the formula has the big Ram air
scoops on it,
right?
Right.
The,
the,
the two big snorkels that come in with a
tesla.
Dope.
There it is.
Woo.
That's a transient and minds the
formula.
Ooh,
look at that car.
Like that yellow one on the right or
that a gray one formula.
Oh.
So I've been driving that around quite a
bit and hotchkiss did all the suspension
on it,
will look,
did the brakes.
It stops in a heartbeat.
That's nice.
Magnaflow exhaust,
that's one of the few cars that I liked
from 75,
like it feels,
I feel like everything after 71,
it's real risky in a way.
I mean some of the styling lines of
these mid seventies cars.
I kinda like it in the obnoxiousness of
it all.
But uh,
and you know,
when whatever you get with these as far
as like.
So this car came with a 400,
the one that I bought and uh,
it was like seven and a half to one
compression.
So it was just a total dog.
People like,
Hey,
do burnouts.
I'm like,
I wish that was the year that,
I mean the years where the gas crunch
was on and they started making these
cars gas efficient,
right?
Well,
are they attempted to in some way,
and not to mention they would,
um,
they started trying to incorporate a
small dog,
uh,
elements to try and reduce the amount.
A small thing,
but they were just highly inefficient
the way they were going about it with
the air stuff and different processes
that were like things connected to the
heads and it was bad news.
Yeah.
It was a rough time for America during
the rare.
The rare times that that is,
right?
Yeah.
One of the rare times,
it was a rough time for cars,
like from 71 to the eighties all through
the eighties.
We just make dog shit.
Cars made some real,
real,
real snoozers.
Pontiac was one of the few that was
putting together a decent looking car.
The firebirds and the Trans Ams and then
of course corvette corvette's still had
some good looking cars in the seventies.
They did and especially because they
even with the lower horsepower motors
car,
so you could still get up there and
hustle even into like 77,
78.
You had the six point six three or the
400 or the four or three.
I guess by that point in the Pontiac's
right now,
chicks are turning off their fucking
radio in mass.
I don't know if any chicks wanted to
tune in to listen to what I had to say.
Anyway,
you're Josh Barnett,
chicks one here.
What you have to say,
they want to learn the ways of men,
the ways of men they want to learn.
They to.
There's a lot of fake men surrounding
using signals.
You know,
I have a theory that a,
so not that long ago,
I maybe just a handful of years ago,
I finally got like a leather biker style
jacket.
And so fonds kind of.
Yeah,
but.
And old ray every time,
but every time I smacked something
electronic doesn't work better.
So they're.
Yeah,
he had a magic touch pro.
Absolutely.
The ladies loved him.
Yeah.
Keeps her dildos in shape.
But uh,
he uh,
alright.
So I got this jacket and I've always
wanted one ever since I was a kid and I
went to this store in New York because
there was no,
there wasn't a location locally where I
could just try the jackets on and I
didn't want to buy an expensive jacket
and have to send it back.
All this stuff.
So I was in New York,
went to the store,
found the jacket that fit me,
loved it,
bought it,
been wearing the ever living crap out of
it,
taking it all kinds of places.
It's been nasty.
Black metal mosh pits with it on.
I've been all around the world with it.
Have been in far eastern Russia.
A leather jacket is made to tell a story
eventually at the end of it,
but people will go,
oh,
you know,
do you ride a bike?
I'm like,
no.
The reason why I have this jacket is
because of Mad Max road warrior.
Because when I saw that as a kid,
those jackets looked bad ass and you
know,
here's the bronze,
the,
the MFP running around in their falcons
just tearing ass and blowing shit up
wearing these jackets and I want a
jacket like that.
But I started to notice that this jacket
was everywhere.
Everywhere.
Everybody,
everybody was making a version of this
jacket somehow or some way this biker
style jacket guys are wearing it
everywhere.
Chicks are wearing it everywhere.
And then I'm like,
oh,
that's a weird fashion trend.
I didn't really see that comment and
then as I started to think about it more
and more and more,
it seems like there is a attempt within
society to try and present the image of
toughness,
right?
So from haircuts to jackets to all these
different kinds of things that
everyone's trying to appear to be tough
and bad ass all the time without,
but people aren't going out there and
necessarily risking it like they used
to.
They're not,
they're not in generally taking on these
jobs that are dangerous or,
or even just your people want to have
muscle cars but they don't want to work
on them.
They don't want to.
It's like by having the item,
it somehow implies some sort of
character.
Yes.
Some sort of toughness,
some sort of a rugged element to
yourself.
Like,
you know,
I'm a bad ass.
Like you've gone through it,
right?
No one's checking it.
You're falling off your bike,
going 70 miles an hour and just rolling
and dust yourself off and you'll see all
the,
like,
uh,
like the 30 year old Hollywood type
dudes with the manicured beards and all
that on their Harley's that have all
been a church turned into choppers and
like,
okay,
it's like a,
a,
a big show of,
of toughness without,
because people aren't going out there
and living tough lives anymore.
Is it toughness or is it coolness and
are the same?
It's,
it's,
I think it's a coolness related to the
idea of being tough and attempt at
authenticity.
Correct.
And,
uh,
you know,
to use a term masculinity,
right?
And even though,
uh,
a woman that's appearing to be tough,
I mean,
you would call it a masculine trait even
though that doesn't mean that they're
being a man.
She's putting out a signal,
right?
Uh,
a chick that,
whereas like a leather jacket and rides
a bike,
she's putting out a signal like,
you better be a bad motherfucker if you
want this bitch or I'm going to girls
into the previous.
Could still apply to the latter.
But,
uh,
it's,
it's like,
um,
you know,
I'm a bad motherfucker.
All right,
whatever,
whatever vibe you're trying to put out
there.
And then you go and you're like,
well,
okay,
what's bad motherfucker about you?
I don't take no shit.
Yeah,
sure you do paper.
I don't take any shit.
My agent calls me.
I tell them to fuck off.
I walked in,
I nailed that audition.
I didn't even have any product in my
hair.
I don't give a fuck.
You don't know me,
man.
I'm different.
It's just,
it's just a little,
it's a casual observation.
It's totally anecdotal,
but it just seems like people are
attempting to try.
And it's like things I always tell
people about looking at human history,
I go the,
the,
the issues that we deal with,
the things that affect us or not new
just in a lot of ways are just more
magnified there,
especially with social media,
social media,
I believe like picks and praise on
certain elements of our way of being,
our process,
uh,
and it.
And it heightens our responses to
certain things.
But it also heightens what we see from
these responses because when somebody
is,
let's say,
massively insecure,
so social media can really pray,
help play hell on that and make you feel
more insecure,
especially if you're putting,
depending on where you're putting value
on what you see or what is said about
you or how you are necessarily if you're
comparing yourself to others.
Also,
when you respond to that in some way
through your own social media,
be it by trying to take more grandiose
photos or,
or,
I don't know,
whatever sort of
signaling of,
of how to make up for that.
It shines even that much more to
everybody else.
So what you do get seen as much as you
see what everybody else does and then
you're given an option on how do you
react to that?
Well,
if you're not,
I mean these are the sort of.
You can go back into old books on
philosophy and uh,
you know,
old historical texts,
insecurity is not going anywhere.
We're not all that much more different
from a thousand years of 2000 years of
3000 years.
And the way we react and respond to
things than we are now,
it's just that all these things are
amplified under the,
the elements of technology that are
around us and how they can affect us and
how much easier it is for the,
for those things to get to us.
Radically amplified.
I mean I see people fighting with people
on Instagram,
you know,
see people fighting with commenters.
If someone posts something and then
other people shit on them and then they,
they take their posts and comment on
that and,
and you've got to go,
this is like hours of your day man.
And people just sniping at you for the
clothes you're wearing or your fake lips
or whatever it is,
something right?
And you,
you,
you could say,
well,
you know,
you've got the person who's got a WHO's
turned their social media to a very self
absorbed sort of a platform.
Right?
A Lot,
a lot.
That's a lot.
And then even in amongst that,
it's like,
well,
I mean to a degree,
if it's your social media and you are
the prime element within it,
of course it would be a bit self
absorbed,
but yeah,
but I think there's more nuance to it
than that.
And it's not just to pick on say,
you know,
the gals that are taking all the sexy
selfies and all that kind of stuff.
There's the dudes that do essentially
the same equivalent and it's all in you.
Often.
It could be in a response to drive
attention towards themselves,
but what do you,
why do you want that attention in the
first place?
And then of course that's something that
you can't know until you know the
person.
Exactly.
Well,
a lot of girls make a living off of it.
A 100 percent.
Yeah.
There's a lot of girls that they do like
sponsored tweets or sponsored instagram
posts at once.
They can get foods are making a living
off of instagram that way for like that
got famous for girls.
It's like girls with big asses and
there's one girl that I just started
following her whole instagram,
her ass.
That is it,
man.
I was thinking it was a terrible thing
to think,
but I was thinking if a dog ever came
over and bit her ass,
she'd be out of work.
That's it.
It's fucked up.
She's have an arcane spray of of hugging
gels.
Shooting advert should have Kevlar pants
on.
Everywhere she goes.
That asks Lloyd's of London.
I have a.
What will you give me per cheek on
insurance.
I mean she has a tremendous ass,
don't get me wrong,
but it's just weird when there's this
like one here's body part that
essentially defines your identity like
this does,
which,
which is weirder that this,
this person with this fantastic
monumental,
epic level ass is out
there taking photos of it and putting it
out there for people to see or that
people not only continuing to look at it
but more flock to this.
This a religious icon of an ass
apparently.
Yeah.
Well it doesn't get old apparent.
It never gets old.
No,
not for dudes.
I mean for girls is there like one,
but I guess it's abs isn't abs?
Like what is the one body attorney?
Jamie.
Jamie,
yeah.
Hey,
tell us about what the rules are.
But for girls it's a wallet.
Look how fat as long as it has an effect
of fat watt.
But uh,
it will also,
it wouldn't be surprised that women in
terms of that,
that kind of shallow aspect of social
media in that way could,
could make more impact out of it.
Because even when you look at,
say all the men's Mag,
all the women's magazines,
all that kind of stuff.
And like women want to look at young
women,
right?
So women are even driven to look at
Honda.
We're of course obviously driven to look
at hot women.
Well women know about filters to like,
oh this bitch is using filters.
Look at her.
That is not what she looks like.
She looks like a cartoon face look at
her face and then they're trying to find
out what filter that was.
It felt a beauty filter.
What Cameron does she use?
Yeah.
If a girl's found out that there was
like one camera that really did it,
it would be every girl would use that
one phone that has that one camera.
Exactly.
Like they nailed it.
I guess they're all pretty good now,
but if there was like one standout phone
that took better selfies,
like that would be the one that they
used.
Oh,
it would be a marketing avalanche
towards that demographic for sure.
Your,
your rear phone,
like if you have a phone,
the camera on the back.
It's always more powerful than the
selfie case.
But the bigger lens and for chicks
that's fucking bullshit.
Like they need it.
They need to reverse the other way.
I need like multiple lenses.
You can choose which one you need to.
Like I know at my friends look like I
see them.
I want to see myself selfie sticks.
If there was dudes only dudes on the
planet,
they'd be no selfie sticks.
That shit would've never been invented.
You don't think so?
No.
If we found.
If it was only men and we found a guy
with a selfie stick,
that would be the guy who fucked like
hold them down.
This is this.
Did you get injured?
Is this a walking stick?
It's a portable baton in case you get
attacked.
Are you using that to take photos inside
of a bear cave because you've got to go
in.
Do you want to make sure we know where
the Grizzly is?
Are you a,
you know,
putting that thing around corners,
the score that rabbit is and get it?
Is that what you're doing?
Because if not,
I've got a problem with that.
My arms are short dudes with selfie
sticks.
That is a dark thing.
There's something about it like holding
it up.
Hey,
I'm in front of a blah blah blah.
Why is it,
why does that bother you?
It doesn't even make sense,
like why is it okay for me to take a
Selfie with a regular Selfie Lens?
But it's a problem for dude as a selfie
stick.
I don't know.
It just seems a bit obnoxious perhaps.
Well,
it seems that way.
I can't say that I have a reason why it
makes sense.
Make me,
hey,
maybe it's simply because we view it as
something that we see women do it more
and so we,
we think that a man is somehow doing
something well.
It's like mentally,
I don't know if a man gets fillers in
his face.
You ever see like a older dude gets
fillers in his face and like,
Bro,
I didn't want to pull him aside.
I'm sure I have.
Yeah,
you want to go?
No,
just don't.
You're going to be wrinkled.
This is just it.
You're 65 years old.
You got to let it go.
It's letting go on its own anyways.
But some,
some gals can kind of pull it off and
you feel bad for them,
but they still are kind of pretty
political,
you know,
personally myself,
I'm not really all that into the.
Especially manipulating the face like
that for anyone.
I just think that it's,
it's one that the potential for it to go
really badly,
real.
They're into it.
Just I think that people.
You don't have to look perfect to be a
beautiful person.
Yeah.
Yeah,
your personality,
your personality is at least as
important as the way you look and if
your personality is such that you need
to shoot plastic in your face in order
to feel good about yourself.
You know,
I've got to go,
Ooh,
like what?
What's happened in their below,
below the surface.
It could be a indicator of something
more serious that that no matter how
much filler,
how nice it could look.
Maybe there's still gonna be an issue
per se.
It's also one of those things just like
anorexia or bodybuilders that can never
get big enough where they have body
dysmorphia,
people don't know what they really look
like.
Do you?
Do you know about the FIBONACCI
sequence?
The numbers,
right?
It's the golden ratio.
It actually applies to facial features.
See if you can find something on that
now to see documentary on that.
Right,
and at the time,
and there was something about symmetry
and Elizabeth Hurley when they made that
thing was considered one of the most
beautiful women in the world by the
city,
by the mathematics of it all.
She still wanting them to be.
I don't doubt it that chicks like 88
years old,
she's still hot as fuck.
She's rocking it.
But something about the way your face is
shaped.
Um,
you're,
you're like,
a good example is my friend Ari Shaffir
already has a thin face in a long nose
and it all works together.
Like if he had my nose on his face,
it would be like,
hey,
the fuck's wrong with your face.
But the ratios of the width of his face
and the length of his nose,
the size of his eyes,
all that stuff somehow or another syncs
up.
So you're saying it's not that any one
thing,
it's the sum of your parts.
Yes,
it's all those things go together.
And if one of them is off,
like say if your hair is golden ratio on
the face.
So if you are a,
a black woman and you have white lips,
like a white woman's lips,
people are like,
what the fuck is going on?
Is she even whistle?
Right?
She's got a large nose or a wide nose.
And you know,
why grow this facial hair?
No,
hide my skinny little skinny lips.
I can platelets lips.
You got a viking lips,
bro.
I had been told that this is a.
I've had some girls go,
man,
you're.
You're actually in way better kiss for
than I expected because you have almost.
It seems like you have no lips.
I'm like,
dad,
someone told Kylie Jenner and that's why
she got facial stuff.
Yeah,
I was reading that today.
This is what kind of a loser I am.
Fifty year old man with children.
I fucking pay taxes.
I got a lot of shit to do.
Meanwhile,
I'm reading some article about why Kylie
Jenner decided to take all the filler
out of her face.
It was a fucking article on my google
feed and I was like,
what is this?
Well,
they know.
They know what you're into.
I guess they do.
I don't know how they've got your tagged
science fiction.
How do they know?
They know the inner workings of Joe
Rogan will.
Filler is a fairly recent thing in human
history.
As long as I've been around earlier with
it.
I mean I don't claim to know what's in
What is filler?
Well,
it's okay.
Let's facial filler.
Google that.
What's in facial filler sand?
Jb Weld.
Pando gorilla come.
Yeah,
probably depending on what,
how higher grade it is or and there's
the freshest levels of the gorilla club.
Does it feel like if they touch your
face and you got some shit and then it
makes your cheeks,
some girls would look.
They got rocked like their cheeks look
injectable fillers with face.
Oh Jesus.
A hydraulic hyaluronic acid.
Now seeing the college in a hyaluronic
acid are both going to get absorbed into
your system eventually.
I think that's the good part about it is
that it's temporary and then if you just
let your body raising scour depressions,
enhancing lips and replacing soft tissue
volume lost your facial injections.
Hm.
Huh?
Enhancing Lips.
Get it done.
But that's why it looks weird with girls
when they have big fake lips because of
the golden ratio.
Your face doesn't.
It just doesn't work.
Like go back to that article on the
golden ratio of the face please.
And you'll,
you'll see like they have a.
there's a whole mathematical sort of
algorithm that they can use to sort of
explain what is and is not normal.
The,
the shape of your face.
Like look at um,
what the fuck's his name?
Angelina Jolie.
You remember that song?
There was a fucking song.
Someone.
There was a song,
goddammit.
This is like 2002 something like it was
a song was Angelina Jolie got some big
ass titties.
The name of the song.
It.
Was that a big is that was that.
Was that top 40 amongst me and my stupid
fucking friends?
It was,
it was.
It was a funny song.
Like the dude who sang it.
Is that,
is that funny sober as well or.
That's a good question and you'd have to
ask somebody else.
Those were the years from the.
From 2000 when I was doing fear.
Fact is that it
just stating the obvious is that.
Yes,
it's got some big ass too.
It's,
it's just so stupid.
From 2000 to two,
somewhere around 2007.
I think I was high every day.
It's all a blur.
It's just driving through a hug.
I was so bored when I was doing fear
factor that the only way I enjoyed it,
it was high as fuck.
You're enjoying all eating pig anuses
and people screaming about having a
centipede on their head and after awhile
it got bored,
got desensitized to it.
It just didn't.
I just can't watch general porn anymore.
Right.
It's like if there's not a robot
right in there,
you know,
having sex with a tiger while a midget
films.
It was clearly that stuff does happen.
Right?
Like there's a reason why people like
gag porn is that rule 34 if there's not
a point of it that uh,
it,
if you can think of it,
there's a porn out there and 35 is if it
doesn't exist,
that shall be made.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
It's a fortune thing.
Not that I'm unfortunate all the time,
but oh,
someone's going to an account.
There's something about like,
people getting desensitized that's
fucking absolutely real.
And that's one of the reasons why like
in times of war,
people are capable of doing more and
more awful shit.
It's like you get desensitized,
you get normalized,
like people are very malleable,
you get accustomed to all sorts of
things,
send it to some of those things.
Don't necessarily stay forever.
They're,
they're subjective,
you know,
for that,
that time in that moment and plus there
is everything that's going around you.
And,
and if,
if we're all in here and we're saying
we're drinking coffee when you think
that this is the way to be.
And then other for everyone else are out
and around us and like,
well they're all drinking energy drinks,
energy drinks are actually the best
thing to do.
Uh,
well.
Now there's this other thing that you
see that perhaps then that bleeds into
what?
Oh No,
let's do energy drinks instead.
If you go from that to,
you know,
let's drink a grain alcohol,
well maybe not.
Well,
yeah,
I mean sure,
people just imitate their atmosphere
show
and if someone else is,
you know,
God and war and if they take one year,
your,
your teammates and then cut them to
pieces and send them back to you,
then all of a sudden you're going to do
the same.
And some,
you know,
reprisal.
Yeah.
I used to know a dude who,
uh,
he was a mormon and Mormons aren't
allowed to drink coffee.
I thought you were going to go somewhere
else.
So I knew he was a mormon.
He used to cut people a piece in the
center.
I know you didn't do any of that.
I don't think.
Well,
I mean,
Mormons,
they're just so friendly.
There's something got to be going on
underneath.
If
somethings there's a trigger that you
got to find it,
puts a hole in there.
They get a hole in their magic underwear
and they're just,
that's it.
But I would fucking place down.
I offered them a cup of coffee and he's
like,
no,
I can't drink coffee.
And he had
a fucking.
One of those huge monster energy drink.
Seriously?
Yeah.
He was drinking them all day long to the
point where he was having heart
problems.
He's kidding.
Fucking heart palpitations.
He was drinking.
Oh No.
It wasn't,
wasn't monsters.
It was rockstars wonder which one has
more caffeine?
Find out which one.
I think Ryan has more caffeine than a
monster.
Monster's doable.
Like I drink,
I'll drink a sugar free monster during
UFC broadcasts at the times I drink
those during the,
uh,
the new Japan shows there for hours.
Yeah.
But the problem is you got to piss
whatever's in there.
Goes right to your system like that.
Caffeine ain't helping.
Goldberg used to drink those fucking
things like they were water and he was
always pinging.
Both monster and Rockstar have the same
amount of caffeine per serving,
which is eight 80 milligrams per eight
ounces.
Yeah.
But what?
Haiti is not that A.
Wow.
That's crazy.
That's our list as being 2:40
at or,
or something around there at the whole
can and monster list as being 1:32.
This is to 70 g whoa.
How these little bad boys or two seven.
Goddammit tate.
He kind of made me jump out of his
chair.
Case turned tape.
Try to give people heart attacks,
shadowed tait fletcher.
Shout out to take Fletcher and caveman
coffee.
Yeah.
Um,
there's a weird.
People are weird with trends,
right?
Like whatever the fuck happened.
The acid wash jeans.
I was thinking that the other day,
like people used to love acid washed
jeans.
Remember they'd walk around with genes
with all spoiled us all over.
They're kind of making a bit of a
comeback.
Yeah.
Like fanny packs.
Yep.
In the same.
You were ahead of the curve way ahead of
curve.
I never left.
You're basically a late eighties pro
wrestler.
Yeah.
Right.
Like home cogan.
Like hold Bogan.
Like,
yeah,
right here.
Ladies and gentlemen.
This bitch never left my side.
All leather never left my side.
This is real.
It was made from a big horn sheep that
you,
uh,
you tracked down with an Arrow.
I wish I should get one mate.
I've got these access deer hides out
there.
I should get one turn into a fanny pack.
That'd be dope.
Before on it.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Right.
I hope you don't get any ticks.
No,
there's no tax on those.
I don't think they have ticks in Hawaii.
But uh,
it's weird,
you know.
But that's the thing about paradigms is
you don't really realize it's when the
paradigm is over until you're out of it.
Right.
And so we're in a paradigm now of some
sort and it's easy to get lost in that
and not be able to see outside of it.
What do you think is happening now that
will be ridiculed in the future?
I'm tough.
I mean,
I didn't think that in a lot of ways we
would end up to where we are at this
point and so many of the social and
cultural elements and that didn't even
just specifically stay within the u s
but seemed to be bleeding throughout all
of western society and civilization at
large.
I got one word,
yeezys yeezys.
Yeezys be marked
with that says that's a shoe,
right?
That's just for Jamie.
He loves those fucking things.
He bought me a pair.
I won't wear them.
I told them,
next time I go running in the creeks,
I'm going to wear him.
Jamie loves these God damn thing.
So I'm not.
So I'm trying them on.
That's still got the foam thing and
there bro.
Put them off.
Nope,
come on.
That looks like a sneaker from the
eighties,
right?
I wouldn't even say that.
What would you say this,
by the way,
you're talking to a real man here.
That's okay.
I understand this.
I understand this like the bottom of a.
of a fucking cycle of a form home.
Coleman coolers.
Yeah.
That's just the bottom part.
The ultra.
What is this?
Like a glorified fucking water sock.
This is like the thing.
You see some,
some doofus with a those,
a frog skin things on his glasses to
keep from falling.
Always wandering around in the.
You know,
I don't want to get too wet.
So you wouldn't wear those.
No.
Weird.
Here's what I.
where we're at.
How manly men were these.
That's right.
Chuck Taylor.
Custom chucks with my logo on the side
as was drawn by Dan [inaudible] and look
at that.
A skulls and shit like this.
God damn dirty,
stinky chuck.
I wear black metal tee shirts.
Look at that.
See that chuck's Goddamn classics.
Jamie,
not this.
What is this a fuck's going on here?
Comfort.
Comfortable trucks while I'm wearing.
I'm like,
damn,
I should probably put these on when no
one's looking.
Goddamn being like you're just wearing
Angelina Jolie's titties,
right?
Big Ass souls.
Yeah.
They look comfortable.
Stop pitcher filters.
I could see jp and some disease.
What's that?
Legacy JP and some yeezys jp?
Yeah,
Jordan Peterson.
Peterson.
Oh yeah.
I could see him wearing some atrocious
sandals and no one's looking man that
you'd have to talk to them to,
to,
to do good.
Take those off with a.
with some wool socks on.
Yeah.
Jamie and I were talking about this the
other day.
You're allowed to wear socks with
slides.
No slides,
so there's no right.
There's no toe.
You're allowed to.
Who says guys wear them all the time.
Fuck that noise.
The fuck.
Is that about?
I don't know.
It's a thing loud.
No,
it's not allowed guys wear them all the
toe.
Keep your socks out of your sandals.
We were just in Vegas and there was some
basketball thing going on there.
There was a bunch of basketball players.
Okay.
Half of them slides.
Here's the deal with that though,
and it's.
I can at least say as an athlete that
maybe they've got the slides on because
they're going to take those slides off
and
put their basketball shoes right on.
So for them it's like I'm,
I'm,
I'm out of uniform at the moment,
but I'm ready to go to combat basketball
wise at any moment.
I don't know.
But in general,
as far as a fashion trend,
fuck that noise.
But it looks ridiculous
amongst like rappers see rappers wearing
those things with socks,
it just looks like he just,
I don't know,
like you've given up.
Yeah,
kind of just wear sweatpants all day
too.
Like you're a dude with a wife beater
with your gut hanging out of the bottom
of it and you just fucking kicking back.
Fuck it.
I don't only.
I can't even bend over and tie my shoes
class for the velcro on my yeezys.
Yeah.
Don't velcro.
Well,
you know,
I guess I guess you don't need a real
shoe.
If you throw on,
you walk out with your socks on and you
throw on your sliders and get on your
hoverboard are fucking what your
electric scooter.
Would you ever drive a tesla?
Uh,
I would drive a tesla,
uh,
but you know,
here's,
I got one of my beefs,
not with Tesla's per se in any way,
but I would say we're talking about cars
as somebody,
uh,
out and about,
and they'll,
we'll have some conversation and uh,
I'll bring up some car or talking about
something like the dodge now wasn't a
demon when the hell cat came out.
And so like,
Oh yeah,
those,
those hellcats I've heard amazing things
about how,
not only is it obviously incredibly
powerful and fast,
but that they're massively comfortable.
You could,
it's a gt car.
You could grand tour all over the US and
become free of the whole time and yeah.
And they're like,
oh,
but what about the Tesla?
I'm like,
um,
that's another 40 to $50,000
more.
Oh,
it's almost,
I heard it's as fast if not faster.
I go,
if I'm paying over 100 fucking thousand
dollars for a car,
get better,
be fast,
it better have all this shit like,
and I would talk about certain other in
a lot of times it's like my firebird
doesn't cost that much.
Dude,
I don't care if that Tesla winds,
you just spent $150,000
on a car.
Okay,
well what if cost wasn't an option?
What if Elon Musk,
if I'm elon musk,
I'm,
well God,
I don't think he can not drive a tesla.
He's out there and have a goddamn three
inch exhaust for 70,
you know,
big block I,
Pontiac people are like,
what the fuck?
Yeah,
he probably can't drive anything but
Tesla and Oh,
what a trap.
Yeah,
for real.
But wish I would rather I would rather
drive a car.
I don't feel like electric cars have
soul.
They don't have any.
There's nothing that doesn't
the beep.
Boop,
boop,
boop up in the little printer comes out
and I just doesn't do it for me.
Well,
they're really cool,
but at the end of the day,
the problem,
the problem is it feels good to hear the
rumble of it.
Engine to me in the fucking put that
clutch in and pop that gear.
What does that Elan's to gas cars.
He owns a Jag Jag.
That's an old jag.
That's a hard top.
It's probably a [inaudible] actually.
Those are amazing.
First love.
Wow.
Oh,
it's a roadster.
Okay,
so that top pops off.
Wow.
That's it.
That's shaped man.
Look edible.
What year was that?
Oh yeah,
that's
sixties.
Sixty,
70,
67 and it's a gorgeous.
So pretty.
Let me see that picture again.
Scroll down.
Oh,
look at that.
Yeah,
but there's something about the sound of
combustion engines.
Just.
It's so magnetic.
Teslas are cool.
They're silent.
The that.
I'm sure they're incredibly comfortable.
Oh yeah.
And that pad that they.
Big Ass ipad that you have where your
navigation screen is,
I mean,
is the shit while you're driving and
that thing and you just ask it to play
songs and it pulls them up on spotify.
I'm also a little bit
weirded out by the over elect tronic
element of modern life.
I,
I realized the usefulness of it,
but I always think about,
you know,
when some shit goes south,
like I can't just fix it and we keep
going or if something goes bad it could
go bad and a lot of different ways and
there's a chain of command of bad that,
that it's all linked to that it could go
to as well.
And so I'm just like,
Eh,
just doesn't that.
Plus when you talk about engines,
alright you,
you start up your porsche startup event,
you start up an ls motor and then you
started up next to a big block pontiac.
You started up next to a big block.
Ford and everything has a different
feel,
a different different cam that's in it
makes it sound different,
makes it operate different.
The exhaust,
it's on everything changes based on all
kinds of different elements.
And so the,
the car even of itself,
not just the exterior of it,
but the internal is make it seem like a
different vehicle.
Yeah,
for sure.
Like have you ever been around Ferrari
a?
Not a ton,
no,
but I know they have.
They got the salad.
They had their own Aston Martin is
famous for having.
It's a very specific exhaust.
There's sounds that they have.
It's like a celebration.
It's like better not drive it too far
because it's probably going to break
before the next 12 minutes.
This is fantastic.
Nothing like it.
The way they sound like I used to love
top gear with Jeremy Clarkson.
Show was the best.
Whoever he punched,
he said,
sorry.
The showbread get over it.
Fuck is wrong.
BBC conscious slap.
It's what you were talking about
earlier.
People are pussified there.
Pussified there.
They're playing tough.
They're doing a Goddamn car show with a
bunch of men drinking booze.
You guys got in a fight and you got hit.
Take a little settlement.
Move on.
Give them an apology or,
or even just say,
Hey,
let me hit you one back.
Fine.
I wish I was there.
And Jeremy,
how much money you got?
What you got in the bank?
Got $70,000,000.
A million people wanting to sort of live
at parents' house for the rest of their
life,
except then it goes from being mom and
dad to them being a state of some sort
that does all your work for you because
you don't want to have to take the
responsibility of either winning or
losing that confrontation.
Maybe.
Well,
I think he just got punched.
Was a drunk asshole.
Maybe so.
But if it's on Jeremy,
he could just go to me like,
all right dude,
I'm gonna get one on you.
Yeah,
it's and it's even we're done.
Move on with my life.
But what if the guy can fucking crack
with Paul Dale daily?
Shouldn't have fucking hit him.
Then he shouldn't have fucking hit him.
He hit a barrier.
All.
Well,
that's the realm of people that don't
practice martial arts.
Like how many people get drunk and get
in fistfights that actually know how to
fight.
It's pretty small.
According to the Internet.
It's real small.
He watches the district videos idea what
they're doing.
You know,
they think it's,
I'm always amazed at people's,
uh,
overestimation of what they can do with
their body,
especially in pr and went to pertains to
animals,
like what you would do if an animal's
coming at you or like,
you know what?
My favorite thing to watch is one of my
favorite things in the last couple of
weeks.
I got to stop.
I watched fucking running with the
bowls.
Oh Man.
When is that?
Actually this week I think I have a
bunch of friends over there.
They're going to do that.
Call them,
call them,
tell them you love them to get the fuck
out there.
Don't do it.
Hey,
let's,
uh,
let's get this two ton animal.
Don't think people understand a how
strong those things are.
And B,
how shitty their body works.
People have this idea that,
come at me,
bro.
I'm going to fuck it.
Just get it out of the winning.
Just sidestep it.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
you're on these slick beer soaked.
What is this,
Jamie?
This is the end of it right now.
The sixth of the 14.
What's happening right now?
I can't believe it.
I've been watching videos.
I didn't know it was actually live.
This is so fucking insane.
This is so insane.
People are so insane.
What if it gets a beat on you and then
all of a sudden like A.
Nope.
You're the only one out of this entire
crowd of 500 people right now that it
wants to Gore.
Oh yeah.
Well,
I mean if it finds one that sits still,
it's going have tickets,
frustrations out.
And the crazy thing is,
hey,
look how many people were there watching
this and watching these fools running
around in the middle of this bull fight.
I want to see someone get fucked up by a
bull.
Have you ever watched a bullfight?
Uh,
I have not.
I have seen plenty of clips.
Footage of it.
What?
Have you remember watching a bullfight
yeah.
I'm not interested.
Didn't,
doesn't really do anything for me.
No.
I mean I,
I can up until the point of,
of,
of killing it,
right?
I.
Okay.
You want to go out there and dodge a
bull?
A seems like a bad idea,
but all right.
But then you.
All right.
You've already proven that you can
maneuver yourself out of the way.
No need to spirit and kill it.
It also seems to me that I know it's
tradition.
I know it comes from a different era.
I know I understand that and so I'm not
going to here and then just like
go railroading bullfighting necessarily.
Position is tradition to know there's a
lot of things that are pretty
successful.
Yeah,
it was horrific traditions.
It just seems to me to be a a
bastardization of our relationship with
animals.
Like even.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with domesticated animals,
but obviously factory farming is this
disgusting.
It's nasty shit.
Why?
Why do it?
And there is no I.
it's possible to have animals that are
able to live a more natural way of life
than it is to to jam into a cage and
force feed them until.
I don't know if it's possible to do it
the way we've been doing it,
but the real problem is the way we
expect to be able to just go to Jack in
the box and get a burger.
Well,
we eat too much meat.
Yeah.
In general,
I think that your average person doesn't
need to eat nearly as much fucking
varieties of meat as they do.
They need,
they definitely need meat in their diet,
I believe on average.
Do you know about the carnivore diet?
Now?
See,
here's the thing.
I've been uh,
uh,
I heard you talking to Joel,
you've talked a lot about and then
Jordan Peterson and his,
his daughter.
Oh,
I talked about it with Chris Bell First
who's been on it for,
I think he's been on it for at least six
months or so,
and he's having radical improvements and
one of the reasons that he's having
improvements and then Jordan's having
tremendous results.
And Jordan's daughter as well is
arthritis.
They all have arthritis.
Like Chris Bell has two artificial hips.
I don't doubt it.
Trying to be that market.
Smelly markers smelly.
Chris Chris's bore Chris Board Bell and
Chris is the one who produced bigger,
stronger,
faster.
I met Chris.
I've met.
I've actually never met mark the person.
Chris is a fantastic always guys
backward baseball cap on.
Yeah.
They're both fantastic guys and really,
really smart and just Chris has suffered
from serious,
debilitating arthritis and pain in his
joints his whole life.
Having a carnivore diet,
knocked it out for them and that's the
only thing I was familiar with,
the ketogenic diet and all that kind of
stuff and and having a higher.
It works for me as well to be honest,
to eat that way.
My,
my problem is my love affair with
fucking breads.
You're out there getting a coffee maybe
in the morning like,
damn,
that looks like an amazing croissant
right now.
How it looks even better in my face.
He's like a chocolate croissant.
I do like the chocolate croissants.
You know who's got the best ones?
Coffee Bean though.
Starbucks ones can suck my dick.
You know what I don't eat.
I don't eat.
I'm a Seattle Guy,
but I don't need starbucks for science.
You don't know.
They're terrible.
They used to be okay.
They used to be pretty good.
You know when they went south and they
started putting them in plastic bags,
they give them to you.
They're already sealed up in a plastic
bag back.
No one's at coffee bean.
Have way more chocolate in them.
They're thick.
If you're going to go deep,
go deep.
That's what I say.
I go to the off,
you know the non chain coffee shops that
that will like a coffee,
coffee and food and coffee.
Commissary faced down the street here,
a Russian bakery.
These truck croissants will knock your
deck right into the dirt and bet.
Ooh,
they're thick,
rich and delicious.
Yeah,
I'll go get her number for them.
I got good coffee type.
I,
if I,
if I stick to eating in a more ketogenic
way,
it's,
I feel better.
My joints hurt less.
Uh,
I lose fat easier,
but I still can,
can put on muscle mass.
It's,
it is a better way for me to eat.
And I don't know if there is something
about our genetic makeups,
say meet you JP.
We probably have some crossover
similarity there.
Yeah.
I don't know if there's anything to do
with that.
I just know that it's been useful to me
and I've seen it be,
you know,
that's the way you eat.
I've seen,
I've heard Jordan talk about his
daughter and how useful it's been for
her and as you another one,
I mean she's had her ankle replacement
or hip replacement.
It's like an autoimmune thing as does
he.
It's the same,
same exact issue.
And an autoimmune issue is also what
this radical arthritis's.
There's so many people have these issues
and these are isolated incidences,
you know,
isolated issues that people have,
but you know,
I know people that thrive.
A vegetarian diets.
I have no problem with it.
Yeah,
a vegetarian is a way to go for a lot of
people that are thinking about being
vegan.
Don't be scared of eggs,
folks.
Just get eggs are good for you.
Eggs are great for you.
Just every,
all this fucking Peta propaganda where
they call them chicken periods.
Look,
if you don't want to kill animals,
I get it.
I told her,
I love animals.
Get free range eggs.
You can get them at the fucking farmer's
market and they have a dark orange yolk
and they're fucking great for amazing.
And the chickens don't even notice
they're gone.
They don't give a fuck.
No chicken is going to have eggs no
matter what.
They just lay them,
unless there's a rooster that to,
uh,
to fertilize it.
They just got to fucking lay eggs.
It's just free food.
It's like a gift that they give you.
A keystone chickens.
Fuck,
I had six eggs this morning for
breakfast.
They're incredible.
They're thicker and heavier and it's
actually good for you.
And of all things,
one of chickens,
one of their favorite little snacks.
That's something that they just
absolutely love.
Eggs.
Chickens,
chickens love scrambled eggs.
Yeah.
You know what they really love?
They love shells.
They love the shells.
Shells.
Yeah.
No,
they love more than that.
Mice,
mice,
lizard.
Tail.
Fuck.
Vicious little fuckers.
Yeah.
But you know what they don't fuck with
squirrels.
Well,
they're a little big,
but yeah.
But they just don't even try like
squirrels,
like a rat,
you know?
It's basically a rat.
Everybody loves squirrels.
Even chickens.
Step bushy tail.
It's crazy.
That bushy tails all.
You needed that cute haircut.
Like this little snap and awake and uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
I had a,
I had four chickens and one time,
uh,
there was a little miniature Chihuahua,
a little chihuahua or a little mini docs
and maybe are many men.
It was a min pin and it got into the
yard and ended up in the backyard and
the four chickens cornered it and
wouldn't let it leave and so it's back
there whining and yelping and
eventually,
uh,
my ex at the time went and caught the
dog and then try to figure out whose it
was and what have you.
And it turned out it was chipped,
I think in you got given somewhere where
someone could then track them down,
but it was just hilarious that these
chickens were like,
fuck you,
motherfucker.
You're in the wrong place.
You know else?
Love squirrels.
My dog.
That's a different animal all together.
Yeah.
Marshall,
they hardly ever catch him though.
He got that one.
It was like this sweet golden retriever.
That's kind dog who loves everybody.
Yeah.
He likes fucking up squirrels too.
Well,
the problem is the squirrels go into the
chicken coop.
They'll find a way into the chicken coop
and they steal all the chickens for food
and Marshall just decided to wait
outside of the chicken coop because he
knew where the hole was.
I just sit in there and snatched that
motherfucker and then just with the
biggest shit eating grin on his face.
Yeah.
Mrs.
Rogan does not like the squirrels.
She doesn't like the squirrels getting
into the chicken food.
To me,
I feel like we just buy more chicken
food,
poor little squirrels that they're
hustling.
It's hard life being a squirrel.
It is just trying to get these,
you know,
trends trying to get by trying to live
your life are out there.
They all have this peer pressure from
all these other squirrels.
And then he started smoking young.
Yeah.
They find this sweet spot where all
these fucking nuts and all this grain is
like,
this is amazing.
Yeah.
Squirrel gang.
I can tell when they fucked up though,
they start stealing eggs.
They still stealing eggs.
These cops were trying to roll eggs out
of the chicken coop.
That's when she got mad.
Yeah.
I,
I had no idea that squirrels ate eggs
and then we started finding videos
online.
Jamie pulled a bunch of videos of
squirrels,
role in chicken eggs out of a chamber.
Heard of that either.
They didn't have the motherfuckers we,
they have.
We have egg boxes.
They're elevated egg boxes.
Okay.
The egg boxes like two and a half,
three feet off the ground.
Squirrels got up into the egg box,
got the egg,
chucked it out of the egg box,
lands on the ground.
The getting it in their own egg.
They're clever.
Little fucker's sneaky and they're cute.
So they're like,
I can get away with anything.
They do get away with more.
Like rats must be like,
what in the fuck man,
this shit.
We were wasting water and yet people get
fucked.
Just stab as left and right.
Yeah.
There's no industry for Squirrel killen
like,
no,
not really.
Maybe in the deep south.
And that's not an industry out there.
They get their mortgage is paid by
killing rats.
Like they're driving around in a nice
car from killing rats.
Nolan and nobody cared.
Nobody feels bad.
Like,
Oh,
I'm an exterminator.
We're all racist when it comes to
certain animals and bugs,
right?
People collect butterflies.
Nobody stomp roaches,
everybody stomps,
roaches,
swats,
mosquitoes,
those things.
They will give you everything.
Know all kinds of diseases and shaken
gay fever,
malaria,
and the only,
the only part of the mosquitoes life I
enjoy or think is interesting is when
their larva and they're these fucking
vicious little things at these giant
hook
teeth that will,
can even eat little fish and all that
kind of stuff.
In the ponds too.
When I first moved to California,
I rented this house in Encino and nobody
lived in it for like a year and a half,
two years,
something like that.
And they had a pool in the backyard that
was just sitting there with Gerald Gamma
Green.
There was schools of mosquito larva
swimming around like fish.
I went out into the yard.
I was like,
what the fuck is that?
And the guy was like,
oh,
we'll take care of that.
I go,
what is that?
That's you poisoned.
She's just pour bleach into it.
Yeah.
Well the first thing you do is you
bleach it.
Then you've got to drain it.
You gotta you gotTa,
take all this Goop,
all that shit out.
Yeah.
You got to drain all that water out.
They had to bring it like a machine and
then they had a clean all the fucking
the bottom of the pool.
It was all green and funky.
But the crazy thing is they were moving
through the water,
like,
you know,
I see those,
those big flocks of birds and they all
move together.
They were doing that in the water.
There was fucking thousands of them.
It was crazy.
But then they didn't grow legs.
It would have been a real problem.
It would have been a real problem that
got out and started flying around.
I would have got fucked.
Yup.
There's a meme out there and it's,
I think it's a,
it's a picture,
um,
and it's repeated in,
in,
on the bottom as well.
Have a pita billboard and it's got a,
you know,
these animals all sitting and standing
in a line and it says,
where do you draw the line between food
and friends or whatever.
And then someone else has and they've
got the same thing down there and it's
like a,
you know,
this is normal food.
There's a catastrophic event apocalypse.
I've seen that,
I've seen that.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
being a vegetarian or Vegan is a very.
It's a very first world option.
The reason why people got to this point
is because we figured out a way to
survive eating all the animals around
us,
just like they figured out a way to
survive eating the animals around.
Well I need the argument that Oh,
well this culture is mostly vegetarian
revere this or that.
And it's like,
okay,
well it's also highly developed based on
what was available.
I didn't just say I don't want to hurt
the animals.
Well the only people that did is the
Hindu.
Hindus are fascinating,
you know,
and there's a lot of speculation as to
wash the agriculture civilization.
Yeah.
At certain points in time in comparison
to the rest of the world.
Oh yeah.
I mean you go back and read the Bhagavad
Gita.
I mean they had some really complex
philosophy and really interesting
thoughts about the universe.
But a lot of people believe that that
was due to psychedelic drugs and one of
the,
one of the reasons why they believed
they had this interesting relationship
with cattle but not with lamb was
because cattle shit would grow magic
mushrooms on it.
This is because so much is a big part of
the ancient Hindu folklore and their
religion and their ancient texts,
they talk about Soma and Soma was some
sort of a psychedelic mixture and they
don't know exactly what it was,
but they know that Hindus,
the,
um,
like a lot of the ancient Hindu text,
they deal with some sacraments and they
know that they were into hash.
And like a lot of the Yogis,
Assad dues,
they're into chillums.
They smoke chillums of Hash.
So they knew they were in the hash,
but they think that their aversion to
eating cows may have had something to do
with the fact that these cows would
shit.
And then the mushrooms grow other shit.
And then they would eat these mushrooms
and have these profound experiences.
And so that these,
they thought of these cows as conduits
to God.
Right?
But then there's also the probably drank
the milk,
you know,
they probably used them to plow the
fields to grow their food.
So it's,
it's real.
It's interesting because when a,
when a culture has an aversion to eating
a very specific animal and that specific
animal also is the main source of
psychedelic mushrooms to,
to ignore that connection seems a little
bit weird.
No,
I don't think it's arbitrary.
I think it's something that would be
worth investigating,
right?
I mean,
why not?
Worst case scenario come down to you
have to figure out if something else.
But we'll look at Shiva like,
right.
You see that picture of Shiva?
The Shiva has his arms,
six arms and Shiva standing on like a
little.
It looks like a baby.
And I always,
I am like,
I have a giant bronze Shiva in my house.
And when I bought it,
the lady said,
uh,
this,
Shiva is standing on ignorance.
This is what it's supposed to be.
I go,
I thought ignorance would be way bigger
than that.
It felt like an ignorance will be like a
dragon.
That Shiva was like fighting.
It was much larger than him,
but when you that that thing that she
was doing,
that's what happens when you trip your
balls off.
Okay.
If you trip balls and you were started
moving your arms around,
I would think Josh,
partner,
it's got six on that.
I mean there's so much of ancient Hindu
artwork that is a.
I thought they were just fan in a bad
fart.
Could be that.
Could it be that Jesus.
That's what we'll all have a fire around
it.
Maybe that's what it is.
They're lightened matches,
but the like ancient Hindu art.
There's.
There's this a iconography.
There's like these iconic imagery,
this iconic imagery that you see when
you do psychedelics.
You see a lot of this stuff,
particularly on mushrooms for some
reason.
You'll see like ancient Hindu and
sometimes ancient Egyptian shit too.
I know.
You know,
you can see.
You'll see a geometric shapes appear out
of and you know,
to me I'm just like,
well that's just what you see when
you're poisoned,
but it's a great.
It's an interesting way of looking at
it,
but it's not poison.
That's the thing about it.
It's the way it's affecting the way your
visual processing perturbance of your
visual cortex.
Yeah,
but it's not poisoned.
That's the crazy thing.
It's like the ld 50 of mushrooms.
It's almost impossible to eat yourself
to death.
Like you'd have to eat your own body
weight,
like you would get way too stuff.
Put them inside those fucking
croissants.
So Catholic the songs,
now you're talking,
it might be the move.
So somebody with monster,
that's a term that has continued to go
throughout a.
yeah,
it's like a sleeping pill now.
And then it was also a major element
within all this Huxley's brave new
world,
which uh,
I am.
That was based on that I probably.
So I'm firmly of the belief that what
we're living in is not a Orwellian,
a potential desktop dystopic future.
We're living in a Huxley version because
Huxley and Orwell was sought from two
different ways and in orwell was more of
the,
there would be force and violence and,
and direct suppression of individuals
and groups and retrain.
Now there is thought policing and,
and you know,
even though they call them equity,
diversity,
whatever departments.
I mean,
there are people that are there to,
you know,
they have these cabals that,
that try to force everybody to be in
line,
but it's,
you know,
they're not necessarily gassing folks
are beating on them or what have your
shock therapy.
However,
Huxley's version of how this would all
go badly was that everybody would be so
comfortable that there would be so much
luxury and pleasure and that you would
just not fight back.
Yeah.
Anything that they would try to impart
upon you though,
the way they would get you to do is just
make your life even softer and even
easier.
Yeah.
Huxley was right in that regard.
And also all there's so little danger in
the world and so little real drama that
we look for drama.
Of course,
we look forward to all over the place
we've made the world's going on most of
the world.
Very,
very safe,
especially for,
at least for us in Western first world
nations.
There's something that Dave Rubin
tweeted today,
see if you could find this.
Um,
it's real reason that I don't think so.
Now the mayor of Durham,
uh,
apparently said something about Jordan
Peterson,
that Jordan Peterson is not welcome in
Durham,
North Carolina because of his
transphobic and racist views.
What?
Yeah.
Let's see.
I can't read.
That man can make that a little larger.
What a fucking misrepresented person.
Jordan Peterson has become just.
Well,
it's got to be very strange.
We believe that Durham is a place for
all of us.
Black,
white,
Asian,
Latin X.
Oh,
I like how you went latinex instead of
Latino,
because if you say a lot to next,
it's like Latina,
Latino.
You get all the other Latino's.
Yeah.
I'm not taking any chances.
Indigenous and mixed race,
Trans and CIS sisters in the real word.
You're getting crazy.
Mayor.
Gay and lesbian.
Queer and straight scissor thing.
Queer to cover all of it anymore.
I'm always confused by that.
It got very open vague term.
I mean,
and maybe there is a in there.
Maybe there's some sort of accepted
standard for what?
What defines queer versus
getting an asexual.
Is that all right?
How come you didn't put that in the
asexual people?
You should march out now.
They're attack the asexual activist
lobbies coming from those who seek to
exclude or deny the humanity of others
will find was interesting.
That's an interesting statement that
people like to make deny the humanity
like who said that you who's denying
your humanity even even assholes,
right?
I mean even some of this is just a
prick.
It's like they can't.
You just heard it and responded to it.
You're living the life that you want to
live.
How can they deny your humanity will
look at this?
We wish to emphasize that a person's
right to free speech does not include
the right to a platform or an audience.
Well,
here's the thing.
You can't deny that people are listening
to him and enjoy his work,
but if you're gonna make these broad
statements.
You have to have some sort of evidence
to back up what you're saying.
I know Jordan Peterson and he's
definitely not a racist.
No,
he's definitely not transphobic or
homophobic or any of those things.
He was against compelled speech.
Jesse compelled speech,
state compelled speech,
meaning that there was a bunch of
different words that they were forcing
people to use that where these new
gender pronouns and they were compelling
and they have human rights councils in
Canada and he is,
he's a mean.
He's a clinical psychologist and he's
very well read and he understands like
Marxism and all the Pid postmodernism in
neo Marxism and its evolution from
classical Marxism and how it's been
influenced.
The difference between emphasizing the
infrastructure over the base.
Just virtue signaling in its worst form.
I am a,
uh,
very,
very familiar with jps work.
He actually sent me a copy of his book
through twitter.
Oh,
that's amazing.
Which was fantastic.
But the way I came across Jordan
Peterson was that as a big fan of nature
and his philosophical writings,
so I'd go on Youtube to see if I could
find lectures on nature and in his maps
of meaning lectures.
And this was before any of the like,
uh,
the issues with BLC 16 really.
I didn't know about any of that.
I was just listening to Jordan Peterson
lectures because of him referencing and
talking about Nisha,
so and then from Nietzsche,
Dostoevsky and all this,
and then it started talk a lot about
Marxism and communism and postmodernism
in reference to each other in other ways
and then the [inaudible] stuff.
And then I was living with a Marxist for
awhile.
So I started.
Are you really?
Yes.
Oh Jesus.
Yeah.
It was not fun.
So.
But at the same time I had to try to
understand what the arguments that were
being made and why.
And so you got to go research them.
So if someone says,
oh,
the wage gap,
blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And I'm like,
okay,
well I guess I need to look up the
research on what that is.
Then you come back and you go,
oh well that's actually not an apples
for apples comparison and it's not 70
percent on the dollar and you just go
into it and then they just look at you
and they go,
no.
It's like I,
I read,
what's your source?
Well,
this thing I read that source,
it doesn't talk about education level
job for job hours work like it does.
It doesn't.
I mean no one's saying that things
couldn't be better.
It's just different.
Heard this argument before,
when you hear about the wage gap,
the gender wage gap,
it's not the people doing the same job.
That's what's this.
This is the best way to them.
It's not people doing the same job and
it's not people working the same hours.
The reason why men make more money as
they do different jobs now are those
jobs more difficult for women to get is
a real question.
Some of them I imagine they are perhaps.
I mean I never doubt that there is a
potential sexism or any sort of ism to
some degree in some sexism coming from
both sides of the tracks.
How many women want to be working on a
fucking oil rig out in the middle of or
doing pipelines up in a frozen south,
North Dakota or something,
and they did,
and how many of them are physically
capable of doing the work to which isn't
a woman's fault at all and you can't.
I wouldn't hold it against anybody or.
And if they didn't,
if they did,
did not want to choose to do that kind
of employment.
There's nothing wrong with that either.
No.
You know,
if a woman wanted to go off and make
artisans soap,
right?
That motherfucker could make the best
soap with essential oils that are the
best for like,
you know,
like how you use the fence soap stuff.
Like if that was a woman that came and
created all of that,
that's a valuable,
respectable,
fantastic thing that they just didn't
require physical strength anyway.
Don't,
don't diminish the compliments of
someone else just because it doesn't fit
what you think is.
Well,
the problem is when we get into teams,
man mean toxic tribalism is the real
problem.
The real problem is people getting
teams,
whether it's male versus female and this
mayor of Durham Guarantee,
well it's a lot of this stuff is
weaponized.
So most of the stuff about the
patriarchy,
which I'm also in ingredients with
Jordan Peterson,
you know,
that doesn't exist.
That's not the way that human history
has has rolled out.
I don't buy that at all.
Not to end or the wage cap.
These are weaponized things.
They use them in a weaponized way to try
and destroy your,
your argument or your position or your
way of being.
It's a weaponized administrator point of
view by saying it's what's your white
privilege talking?
Sometimes I get a lot of white privilege
today.
I'm so white,
a big white,
very,
very white with a red beard from the
Pacific northwest.
How much?
How much can you get any white?
But if I get any wider,
I'm going to be wearing a fucking
birkenstocks with socks on.
You should have a tail and a man bun is
a bowl,
a ponytail.
But,
uh,
it's,
these are,
these terms are used in,
in,
in conflict.
Well,
and when,
why wouldn't they be?
Because most of the,
the source material,
the creation of the,
these sort of ideological viewpoints are
from postmodernist,
neo,
Marxism,
and it's all based on the concept of
conflict theory.
So there's always going to be an
oppressor and oppressed.
So if what you are doing is,
uh,
is trying to
argue with or even just make your case
to someone who's an oppressor,
well it would be weaponized because as
far as you're concerned,
everything they do is weaponized against
you.
Right?
So you've already chosen a
confrontational position.
There's also a problem with people
wanting to be.
Right.
That's human nature.
But I also like,
whether it's someone who's a
postmodernist or someone who is a
staunch conservative,
people go into any discussion with a
presuppose or they have a preordained or
are they have a collected group of ideas
that they have attached themselves to
and they do not want to let those go.
No,
and you have yours and I have mine.
It's very difficult for people to just
talk and very difficult for people to
just someone to lay out their their
position and someone else to lay out
their position and to people to like
cordially discuss the merits of each
position with an open mind.
It happens so rarely and it's something
I try so hard to do and it's something
that it took me years to cultivate the
mindset to not,
not have these preexisting conditions,
preexisting ideas or if I do have them,
don't attach myself to them and be ready
to abandon them at any moment.
Like under the,
under new evidence.
Sure.
And it's,
there's no problem in saying,
okay,
well I believe a new believer B and we
both believed them to be correct.
Well,
tell me why I am,
why a is incorrect or better yet.
Tell me why you believe what you believe
and you know,
let me get into some reason.
What are the facts and let's find if
those facts are real.
It's right.
And I used to,
you know,
I'd have these conversations with this
person used to that I was living with.
I would say like,
well,
you just always have to be right.
I go,
no,
I don't have to be right,
but if you're going to make a claim,
you're going to have to defend your
argument and I'll defend mind,
but ultimately I don't care if I'm wrong
because being wrong only means that I
could then perhaps work towards a way of
being,
the having the most understanding that I
can have.
We as human beings are wrong so much
more than we're ever right,
but by being wrong,
but by making mistakes,
it's like a through martial arts by
being on the mats and you know,
God,
I'm going to get this guy's ankle right
now.
Oh,
fuck that up.
I fucked that up.
I got caught up.
Fuck that up.
You can't get to the point to where
you're like,
oh,
this is how you set it up.
This is the way that you can.
I wasn't securing the knee well enough
so it was always sliding out of position
and I couldn't,
you know,
keep the leg framed in such a position
where when I applied my hold,
the pressure went through the joint that
I needed it to.
Nothing.
None of that happens until you make
mistake after mistake,
after mistake after mistake,
and there's nothing wrong with,
with before making a move,
moving forward on something to sit back
and to study a little bit and to try and
understand somewhat of the landscape,
but eventually the only thing you could
do is you just got to go,
right.
You know,
analysis paralysis through analysis
isn't gonna help you either.
Well,
I lived a good portion of my life
wanting to be right always.
Sure,
and it's a toxic mindset.
It's terrible for you.
It's terrible for you because you don't
grow and then you have to live in denial
and then you have to always tell
yourself that you were right and they
were wrong.
Even if you get out debated or even if
you're faced with new evidence,
you,
you try to ignore that new evidence.
I know the mindset,
I,
I lived in it for many,
many good to be in.
It's an easy place to normal and it's
hard to.
It's hard to relax yourself.
Just realize that you are not facts.
You are not your ideas,
your not your opinions,
your,
your you,
and if you attach yourself to these
opinions,
these ideas like you're going to,
it's a fucking trap.
Like you have to know what,
like here's,
here's something I know for a fact,
this wood is hard,
but I've hit this,
would meet with my knuckles.
That shit's hard.
If it dropped on you,
it would hurt.
These are undeniable facts and the.
There's a gang of those that you have in
the world.
There's a gang of undeniable facts.
What I cut down.
Objectivity.
Yeah.
Whether or not Marxism can be
successfully implemented in the large
scale with a,
a sensitive,
compassionate group of human beings that
all live together.
Who Kenneth,
I don't know.
Doesn't seem to be.
Yeah.
Well,
I don't know though.
See what I'm saying?
Like this is a,
this is a comp.
It hasn't been done before.
A socialism never really worked,
but can it work?
Did the argument that it can't work.
It seems to me that doesn't make any
sense either.
Like maybe you could work well the
argument that it could work is that but,
but see what I'm saying like these are.
These are like really to think about
Rod.
Yeah.
Complex nuanced concepts that need to be
discussed up and down and back and forth
and you also need to look at the weight
of human history,
the myriad times it's failed,
right?
And in human history and even in ways
that,
which is not directly related to say
Marxism,
but just to look at patterns and trends
and ways of people of operating and to
see how okay,
well given a different circumstance,
how would that process work within this
one or this one or this one or this one.
And then even if you wanted to say,
well,
if you're like,
well I don't think Marxism would work
well you can't say that until you
actually study what Marxism is and what
its principles are.
Because if you don't understand the
argument,
and this is like,
you know John,
John Stuart Mill,
you can't just defend your side without
knowledge of the other.
Yes.
You have really no opposition to.
Your position isn't any better than
theirs.
Yeah,
that's a really good point.
I mean,
I think everybody should do that no
matter what you're looking at,
like whatever you're trying to defend,
look at even even if it's something
horrible and it's like a racist
position,
find out why these people support
so they believe it.
Right?
And so what?
Why do they believe this racist
position?
What is it about them that they think
gives it validity and you can look at it
and go,
I could see where they could take this
way too.
It's extreme in that that,
I mean that's nonsensical,
but you see where it started or you can
see like that.
That's everything about this is,
is clearly driven by something else and
not the not what they claim so
well,
it's also the,
one of the things about society,
so we really have to take into
consideration is the momentum of the
past.
Like there's this country has a unique
freedom to it because it was literally
created by people who decided to get on
a boat and risk traveling across the
ocean to some new land.
Yes,
it's a country filled with savages like
crazy people that took wild chances and
did wild things because of it.
And if you look at the history of this
country that's clearly established by
look at the art,
look at the music,
look at the things that have come out,
the comedy,
all of these things that have been
created,
the cars,
all the different things that have come
out of this one place and this one place
just happens to be the most recent place
with the least amount of historical
baggage.
Yes.
But then you look at the places that
have the most amount of historic baggage
like Africa or you know,
some parts of Russia and these are
places where they have the hardest time
breaking out of these,
the weight of the cultural momentum of
the past.
You know,
it's,
it's very difficult for people to,
to radically change and established
system that has existed for a thousand
years.
Well that's true,
and if you were to say think about
communism and the Soviet states in the
length of what constitutes human history
is has only been gone for.
It was only,
it was around for a short time and it's
only been gone for an even shorter time.
Like come on and it's gone,
but it's still a dictatorship over
there.
Yeah,
I guess they're trying to that Russia to
cheer about that lady in Iran.
That's she's going to jail that.
Dancing and dancing?
Yeah.
Oh no,
the Egyptian girl.
The girl,
the Lebanese girls going to jail for
she.
She made a youtube video about getting
sexually harassed in Egypt.
So they sentenced her to eight years in
prison.
She's 22 years old.
Holy Fuck it terrifying.
She's a young 22,
24,
something like that.
She's young and they sentenced her to
eight fucking years that the people here
in America or western the Western
civilization at large.
Just fucking.
They just put on the blinders about
stuff like that.
It's like there are places,
and I'm not going to demonize these
places either,
but at the same time you as a 22 year
old could have a complaint and say,
Hey,
I am like,
you know,
this thing happened and I'm,
this is fucked up,
and all of a sudden they can go,
Huh,
you think that was fucked up,
boom and throw your ass in jail or have
you executed or whatever.
I mean,
it's like,
okay,
well I guess I don't have the right to
express myself.
Whereas you know,
people will show up and bang on doors
and do all kinds of crazy shit.
When Jordan Peterson comes and does a
talk and the thing is they're allowed
to.
They're allowed to protest what he has
to say,
counter protests if they want or to
express their unhappiness with things
political and things,
media way.
Anybody can say what they want in terms
of what makes them unhappy without fear
of the government silencing you.
Right.
That's a major thing.
It's a major thing and this poor girl in
Iran,
she's just dancing.
I know people that are always rail
against Islam or Islamophobia.
There's so much Islamophobia in this
world.
Yeah,
sure there is.
You're right,
there is.
But you know what else there is,
there's also radical Islam and radical
Islamic governments that are putting
women in jail because they fucking damn
religious.
And that's happening right now.
It's just resist religious zealots
training.
And while I have,
you know,
people will often get into a
conversation about this and they'll
bring up,
well what about the Crusades or what
about this?
Like,
go,
hold on.
These are all relevant things to.
And while the Crusades are not nearly as
cut and dry as you think they are,
in fact,
which two it ended in the fourth crusade
to two groups went down there,
uh,
and then end up fighting each other.
It's like you're both Christians.
Yeah,
what the fuck are you thinking?
But then you had things like the
inquisition you have,
you've had all kinds of stuff.
And it's like,
yeah,
no,
you,
you just,
that doesn't erase this.
And that doesn't,
they don't balance each other out.
It's just,
it's just.
And it's because it's one religion and
not the other.
It doesn't make,
it's the,
the,
the motivations are the same,
that kind of comes,
it comes from the same concept.
Even if it's not technically the same
religion.
Well,
it reinforces it in my opinion.
I mean the idea that it's not the idea
that Christianity is so amazing and
Islam is so bad.
It's that ideologies force people into
very terrible behavior.
They can,
they can very,
very much.
And they often do.
Yeah.
I mean,
most of the time it goes bad when you
have a powerful,
potent ideology that dominating
well imagine,
okay,
you had a Christian zealotry and let's
say Islam and Christianity had swapped
and Islam had all kinds of reformations
and different sex break off from it and
all this and it become more like
Christianity is in this modern era.
But Christianity stayed in a more,
a less developed sense and had a more
rigorous fervin zealotry in terms of
adherence to doctrines or at least or
even a,
um,
interpretations of doctrines and certain
ways to estimate stocks.
So,
but within this context of the modern
era.
So now you have the Internet.
So any,
let's say,
you know,
you only got like a million people in
the world that feel this way,
but these million can all connect with
each other via social media,
very different electronic ways.
Um,
they can create a weapon where they can
weaponize things much easier.
They can coordinate,
they can.
It's not like the Crusades where you had
to get money from a king and other Gulf
other monarchs get together.
All these troops get together,
all these supplies,
marched them all down into the Middle
East to where you've got the Turks
waiting for you that they've done the
same thing.
And then you guys all meet up on these
different points of battle.
The,
you could literally be at war all over
the world,
all day,
every day,
all at the same time because of the
modern advances of technology.
And not to mention you have firearms,
you have explosive and chemicals and
things that you can use to your
disposal.
It just,
or a truck,
right?
You didn't have,
you know,
six ton trucks and drive into a crowd.
That's just technology.
It's,
it,
it helps,
it makes our lives better.
But in other ways it can also create
calamity for us and it's really their
tools.
You know,
social media is a tool.
I think the social media is,
if you were to track mass,
the mass shootings that have happened,
the rise of social media and the rise of
mass shootings would,
would be on a parallel.
I really think that it's social media
that's increasing the amount that you
see with the school shooting and things
like that.
I think that because they get fame from
it,
they get fame or you're able to
antagonize someone and they can't get
away from you much more easily.
The,
the resulting mount using a Nietzschean
term in terms of,
uh,
you know,
the resentment,
the resentfulness from seeing other
people having what you think you deserve
or,
or doing,
thinking that they somehow are having
more of what you think you want that as
well.
Why do they get to have it?
And I don't,
or any number of reasons why you can be
incredibly potently resentful.
And now you have this thing that's just
in your life pumping all this kind of
stuff that you all the time.
And I think that it can affect people in
some really pathologically bad ways and
now you have technology to also enact
it.
And if it's not in the end,
you can also easily make the argument if
it's not a firearm,
it could be something else.
And,
and that's doesn't make it any better.
But I think that the,
the rise of social media has been,
is,
is a direct,
a correlator are directly responsible
for the rise in these school shootings
and directly responsible or directly
correlates to it.
I think that there's a correlation
there.
I think certainly there's a lot going on
in society.
I think the big factor,
well there's a lot of factors.
People are alienated,
yes,
there's terrible child rearing.
People have mental health issues,
people are medicated.
There's the big one is now imagine all
that with the,
the technology of social media able to
heighten some of the effects of some of
these things or to create.
So someone that feels alienated.
Imagine now not only do you feel
alienated in the real world,
but then when you're on social media you
want.
It's not a real,
you know,
it's your body knows it's not the real
world,
but you could be alienated out there too
and that which alienates you there could
still penetrate and get to you while
you're out,
what you're away from it.
If people are fucking with you at school
or what have you,
then you're at home,
you're feeling alienated there and then
this is continuing to fuck with you
through social media or other people are
fucking with you on social media.
Let's say you're,
you're playing your video games and
people are talking shit because you keep
getting shot and you know,
a battlefield five or whatever and then
all these things are just compounded
compounder and while no one knows,
I mean there's,
I'm sure you wouldn't necessarily know
that if I say,
oh,
you know,
fuck you knew or something on some video
game that this person is essentially in
real life being told,
fuck you everyday all day,
feeling like the whole world thinks,
fuck you.
How would you know that?
But it could be.
Then that person snaps or that person
has a,
there.
They have a psychological issue that
they're not.
I'm sure there's a bunch of factors.
There's a bunch of facts.
First of all,
does the ability to kill large groups of
people.
Yes.
Which is unprecedented,
right?
The ability to use assault rifles and
just fucking semiautomatic guns and go
in and kill large groups of people.
The knowledge that if you do do that,
it'll make a huge splash and giant
headlines and you'll be.
You'll be infamous.
The fact that a lot of these people are
on disassociative,
so a lot of these people are on like
serious psych medications that we really
have only been studying the effects on
human beings for the past couple of
decades.
There's not a whole lot of data on long
term use of these Ssri for 20,
30,
40 years.
Right.
So you've got varying people's varying
mental illnesses,
varying psychological pressures and
stresses and lives that are just beyond
fucked.
And then they have access to guns and
they want people to hurt the way they're
hurting.
There's a lot of them.
There's a lot of factors going on.
Well,
and you know,
even if they illegally require the guns,
I mean they still have it.
It doesn't matter what the,
in this case,
what the tool is per se,
but
well,
you know,
I don't think we're meant to,
to understand.
I don't think we understand,
nor are we meant to live in large groups
of people where we don't know the people
around us.
That's another thing.
I think that is a really new situation
for human beings.
Don't they overlook
the historical significance of the
population growth,
the population density that has been
gathering as these we didn't,
we get into these,
these,
uh,
high density,
civilized,
civilized areas like cities,
these big cities.
And it changes everything.
Yeah.
And people are less likely to know that
many.
Like if you live in a town of 150
people,
you probably know 150 people.
If you live in a city of 5 million
people,
you probably know 10 people you know,
you know,
people you work with,
you might know a couple of friends,
you know,
unless you're like a really social
person,
sure.
You probably have a way more limited
number of people that you actually know.
Then people that have a tight knit,
small town and small community,
but you know those people are obviously
in your business.
That's one thing.
Fucking what?
I know.
Friends that live in small towns.
Fuck man.
There's,
there's things that come with that too.
A lot of busy bodies.
A lot of people looking over the fence.
I think they had the anal sex last
night.
Jesus is going to punish them to that
next line and storing.
Come through.
You don't.
Fuck fucking speaking of blood fucking
let's talk about Usada.
Yeah.
Without the loop.
We were,
um,
we,
we started this podcast talking about
what we had talked about your,
your situation with Brendan Shop.
And I had talked about your situation.
Were you,
uh,
were you tested positive from a tainted
supplement,
like legitimately tested positive from a
tainted supplement?
It,
you were cleared.
Uh,
but this whole process was a goat rope.
Yeah,
right.
It took a long time to work out and you
didn't feel fairly treated.
Not In the least it,
it started one way.
Then took a fucking curve.
What happened?
Well,
so did you take a.
I took a supplement that had tribulus in
it.
That's all.
It was.
Just a Chinese herb.
It's a Chinese herb that stimulates
testosterone.
And by the way,
barely works.
Yeah,
it's not,
it's not gonna turn you into superman or
anything.
If you get more sleep,
it's better for your testosterone
production than Tribulus.
So it's just tribulus is all it was.
And uh,
they in the supplement itself,
as it turns out,
was contaminated with a sore arm called
Asurion.
But when I say contaminated,
I mean like it had such trace amounts
that the people that did the lab testing
on it said,
well,
clearly just contamination because this
wouldn't help you.
This wouldn't do anything for you
and those.
Let's explain how that happens.
A lot of these places,
I know this for a fact because I am one
of the owners of on it on it as a third
party tested company where we get our
stuff tested by an independent party to
make sure that there's nothing funky
with it,
but we've had some issues in the past
with stuff being in our.
Our earliest formulations of Alpha brain
and weren't supposed to be in there and
what it comes from is you buy your
ingredients from a company.
That company has these vats that they
mix everything in and they don't
properly cleaned the vats and if they
don't properly clean the baths,
you're buying some stuff from China.
Who knows what they're chucking in
there.
They got steroids in there,
they got this,
they got a lot of.
Creatine is tainted with all sorts of
shit.
A lot of different supplements or tank.
And that's what you saw to thought it
could have been at first 10 means yes,
it happened to a Yolo Ramiro.
Yes.
So this stuff is.
Is,
is contaminated.
Right.
And so you sorta was was testing me.
I had had a fight in September of 2016
against our Lawsky and then after that I
was like,
Yo,
I'm just going to take a break for
awhile.
I'm not fighting for,
I'm going to tour Europe and goof off
and whatever.
And then when I get back know I don't
really,
I don't know what I'm going to get back
in the ring.
And they're like all right,
whatever.
And we UFC,
we told them and.
But you saw it,
it would still come around and test and
it's like okay fine,
whatever.
So this is post testing positive.
This is pre.
Pre.
Okay.
And so you fought our lawsky and you
said I'm just going to chill awhile.
Yeah.
And
then one day,
well for one when I'm out there in
Europe and I let them know like,
Hey,
I'm going fucking where the wind takes
me in Europe and I don't have a
whereabouts to fill in because I could
be on a train moving here and moving
there,
whatever.
Which is your prerogative as a human
being.
And they,
they know that and yet then they go
ahead and sent someone to my fucking
house to try and test me while I'm in
Europe and I'm just going,
Whoa,
okay.
Isn't there like an app where you fill
it as an APP?
But if I'm at work,
uh,
you have,
you can fill out where you're supposed
to be ahead of time for the most part.
So on Tuesday the 16th,
I'm going to be at this place from this
time to this time and then,
and then,
but what is your home base?
So if we don't go to these places and
we'll just meet you at your home at some
time or whatever.
He just decided to go to Japan.
You have to tell them,
hey,
today I'm going to take a train to
Osaka.
Today I'm going to go to the mountains.
So you have to give them a detailed
itinerary every day.
Every day.
Okay.
And so I'm like,
Fuck Dude,
I'm just trying to be out here living,
just doing whatever.
I'm not fighting,
but you know,
when I get home,
you test me wherever you want.
You just want to enjoy a vacation,
just travel.
Correct.
And uh,
they go,
they send someone to my house.
I was like,
fuck.
All right.
And then there are times where,
so what happens when they send someone
to your house but you told them you
weren't there?
Uh,
well for one,
no one told the,
I don't know how,
what mechanical elements within their
organization,
how that works,
but they sent someone there anyways.
I'm not there.
That a head count.
Does it count?
Because.
Did you tell them that you were going to
be on the road?
I,
we did.
So they still counted that as you not
being there for a test?
Yes.
Well that doesn't make any fucking
sense.
Well,
it is what it is.
So uh,
but wait a minute,
if they're going to give you a strike,
like don't,
don't.
They have to follow their protocol and
their protocols.
You have to inform them of where you're
going to be.
Right.
So if you did that,
you informed them or you're going to be.
Yes.
They literally told Lewicki and the UFC,
he's not going to be home for almost a
month and he's fucking practically
backpacking all through Europe,
going from place to place to place,
so he's going to be real hard to get
ahold of.
Good time to take steroids.
You get just fucking get back to the
gills.
Yeah,
you'll pass if they showed up in Europe,
you did give them your location and you
told them where you are if they would.
But I was gone.
I didn't feel in any locations.
I just went wherever I went.
So when you went,
wherever you went and your manager told
you,
saw that you were in Europe,
they still showed up at your house in
La.
Okay.
Well that doesn't seem to make any
sense.
And.
And they give you a strike?
Yes.
And so I'm like,
okay,
that's aggravating cowboy strike when he
was at UFC.
So it's stuff like that,
that map and I saw that and I'm like,
well you know what I just did.
I can't fuck around with any of this
stuff.
I don't want people to use this as some
sort of a kindling to try and start a
fire about me and so then I get back
home and they're,
you know,
test me again,
like,
all right,
fine,
whatever.
And then they test me again and I'm
like,
okay,
now you're,
you may just made me late to an audition
as you just showed up out of nowhere.
Cool.
You can do that.
Like they can just show up and you,
you can't say,
Hey,
I have an appointment to keep their
there.
We even,
if you're not fighting,
like say if you're running out the door
and you have a business appointment,
how long does it take for them to test
you?
A.
Depends on what they're doing,
whether it's blood and urine or just
urine.
But with me it's always been blood in
So you can't say,
hey,
you guys are going to have to come with
me because,
uh,
I got to go to this fucking audition.
You know?
I don't know.
I didn't try that.
I would say that get in the car,
bitch,
blah blah blah.
Well,
how you gonna sit there and have someone
draw blood.
I'm not going to you.
You guys are gonna have to do it when
I'm done,
like if you want to keep an eye on me,
come with me the whole way.
I always took it as they showed up.
It's like,
well here it goes.
That doesn't seem to make any sense.
If you have previous commitments and you
have to do something they shouldn't have
like ultimate precedent over your life.
Like they shouldn't be able to just
decide like showing up randomly as they
could.
They could make an argument in some way
on that.
But if you have a life.
Well in any case.
So I take this test and I'm like
alright,
I'm just going to retire for now.
I got too much shit.
I gotta do.
I'm not fighting anytime soon.
I've got my new Japan stuff,
I've got auditions,
I've got all these things.
I'm traveling and I just,
I'm not going to fight.
Right.
So just leave me be.
And then I'm in Japan and the fucking,
the very last test I took right before
retiring.
Oh you're flagged.
I'm like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Really,
really all these tests over all these
years.
Me being the first person to do complete
out of competition or any competition,
random urine and blood testing when I
worked with water and the Nevada state
athletic commission when I fought Travis
Browne,
so no one had ever done actual random
testing before and there was no usada
involved in the UFC yet going through
why did you do that?
It was something that the NSAC wanted to
see done and I'm like,
fine,
what?
I wanted to see that done because you
had tested positive in the past and so I
tested positive before.
In the past you've taken some stuff
right?
I tested positive for anabolics in the
past.
Why?
But I mean the supplement market used to
be way wilder than it used to be.
Well,
and also we'll end the just fighting was
way wild lighting was way while they're.
The supplement industry was way wilder
back in o two.
You could still buy all this shit over
the counter.
That bio for got reclassified the
steroids.
I remember I was taking this shit called
Mag tent number 10.
What was the name of the company that
makes that incorporated incorporated?
That shit.
That shit is all steroids.
Steroids.
It was steroids.
I 100 percent.
I remember meg 10.
He came like 10 pounds in six weeks on
that shit.
You just get Jack.
But that was all over the counter.
Yeah,
it used to be able to buy a lot of
stuff.
And by the way,
liver toxicity is probably off the
charts problems.
A lot of those things that are like
super bad for her but so real effective.
They fucking work.
This stuff worked.
But uh,
so,
you know,
there was a whole different era.
And then with California,
you know,
I,
I had an issue with,
with a contaminant,
what I believe ultimately to be a
contamination,
but I didn't take all the steps that I
had this time.
And once that whole process was such a
motherfuck like this is never gonna
happen again.
So every supplement lot that I took,
I would always keep bits of it behind
for,
until I knew I could get.
I felt there was enough time it expired
and get rid of it because no one's going
to come back and test me.
I passed all my tests.
So.
So once you pass your test,
you would get rid of the old state.
I don't need to keep those lots that are
supposed to take only third party
verified.
That's not what they say necessarily.
They suggested,
I guess a now,
but I know that,
uh,
with this brand of Tribulus I had taken,
I had taken three or four different
other supplements from the same company
and all passed no problem on their
tests.
Right?
So it was just some weird contamination
which does happen again.
Happened at 10 means yes,
it's happened to several folks as far as
I can tell.
I mean I'm not testing their whole
product line,
but it just seemed like a fluke and just
such a simple supplement in any case
over one ingredient deal.
So then they come back and they're like,
oh,
you tested positive for this.
And I'm like,
well that ain't fucking possible.
So then I send in some supplements which
I had to pay for,
to have them tested.
They run them through the testing and
then bang,
they find it all right.
There you go.
There's your deal.
Then they went out and bought a brand
new bottle.
Unopened.
Same Lot.
Tested that one,
verify the results.
Same thing.
Test saying it doesn't happen.
Then Tim means as well.
So then we're in contact with Usada
throughout the entirety of this.
So we don't ever break contact with
Usada.
We have a specific guy and I'm not going
to throw his name out there or anything,
but we have a guy that we spoke to
directly the whole time through my
manager,
uh,
speaking with him and I've seen the
emails.
And so we're talking about how we know
this is a contamination and when,
you know,
when we get done with all this,
why don't we even try to put together
something,
some promotional stuff,
anything that we can do to try and keep
athletes from ending up in the same
issues.
And we'd like to do whatever we could to
help you guys out with this.
You know,
we're not against you,
we're a,
we don't mind being a part of the system
and we understand why you're here and
I'm not against them wanting to do drug
testing or whatever and try to keep a,
a clean and fair playing field.
I get the point of it.
Uh,
so we get the,
the supplements tested,
they test the secondary batch.
They have all their information.
It's like,
all right,
this should be a fucking rock and roll.
And then they got real quiet.
Oh,
okay.
Now you're not talking to us anymore.
What do you mean?
Like you would contact him.
They wouldn't respond.
They would take him a week,
two weeks.
And what were they saying when they do
respond?
Uh,
you know,
I can't entirely remember myself,
but with my manager was in touch with
them.
And what is the protocol?
If someone tests positive for something
that's a tainted Solomon and it's a
third party supplement and where it's
not,
it's not third party verified rather.
Well,
I don't even know if it was third party
verified that anything would be any
different.
Hmm,
okay.
Well,
if it is third party verified and still
is tainted,
yeah,
that would be an issue,
right?
Yeah.
If you tested positive,
he tested positive.
If they found the supplement,
I think the idea about third party
verified is it's much less likely to be
addicted.
It doesn't resolve anything and this is
coming from someone who's in the
supplement business.
There's a certain amount of this stuff.
You farm it out.
So far as I know what the deal is.
There's a period of ineligibility sort
of or basically what happens is you're
effectively suspended until this thing
is all finished out and they tried to
say that you're not suspended.
There's no suspension,
but that's not true.
Well,
no one's going to book your favorite
treats you as you're suspended.
I tried to corner Travis Brown because I
was training him and they wouldn't let
me.
It won't let you.
The corner mission with.
Let me try.
Yes.
Okay.
And so they're like,
you're suspended so you can't.
You can't corner,
but you said you're not suspended.
Yeah,
exactly.
So you're effectively suspended.
You can't work.
You can't even work as a tertiary
individually as a,
as a corner man or anything like that.
He can't be at the event.
And this is after the fact where you
brought them the supplements.
They independently verified that it was
tainted.
Yes.
And uh,
so then we start talking and throughout
the process I said,
look,
I'm not taking a punishment for
contamination and I'm not even fighting.
I'm not fighting anytime soon.
I'm not you.
You can't,
like what you did with means and these
other people,
you punish them,
you know that there was contamination,
but you punish them.
Yeah,
they gave them many months.
Yes.
Have a suspension so that they're able
to compete or make a living during those
months.
And I'm like,
no,
I'm not dealing.
I'm not taking that.
That's not acceptable because I'm not,
that's not what's going on here.
Nobody is doping.
Nobody's trying to cheat the system.
There is no,
I'm not even fighting.
You don't get by punishing me.
You're trying to let guilt on me.
You're trying to make me out to be some
sort of a,
you know,
a guilty party as if I'm trying to be,
have some soreness like I'm not dealing
with,
I'm not taking.
So how did it ultimately get resolved?
Well,
ultimately what ended up happening is we
had to go to arbitration.
That was all,
it was really left to us because then
they started trying to bring up a
stuff from my past and then weigh that
against me as well.
And it's like,
Whoa,
dude,
you guys weren't even around and now you
get to decide to add to the weight of
whatever punishment you want to levy
against me based on,
uh,
things that didn't involve you.
Great.
What were they talking about?
They're talking about 2011.
No,
2008 they went to.
Yeah.
They tried and they tried to say,
well,
oh yeah,
well this happened.
So then therefore,
you know,
now they start talking about two years.
[inaudible] like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
They started talking about suspending
you for two years for a tainted
supplement.
Yes.
Wow.
And I'm just going.
There's no way.
I wouldn't even expect six months.
You think I'm going to take two years?
And so we go and we inquire on the Arbor
and I've done.
I did an interview with the guy that we
were dealing with through skype.
Uh,
we've,
we've been in touch.
It's just like at some point everything
turned and changed.
Their tone changed there.
Even the original penalties,
they were looking to levy increased.
New Shit gets brought in.
It's like they became a completely
different animal as soon as you know,
there was the evidence of,
of contamination and that I wasn't gonna
I wasn't willing to take punishment for
it.
I wasn't.
What do you think their motivation is
here?
I think that they,
and this is just my opinion,
I think the way you saw to looks at it
and it's an easy way to go about it,
is that the more people they deem,
the more effective they appear.
It's their effect.
Their efficacy is based on punishment,
punishments doled out.
Not necessarily not on lack of
punishments at all.
So do you think this is,
you know,
also remembered by the people that are
working there.
So they arbitrarily get to decide how
things go about right.
There's not like a very strict protocol
that they must follow.
They're tainted supplements and for this
no,
there is actually quite a bit of a lever
or there,
there is leeway in terms of how they can
enforce and what they can enforce.
So when,
so it's subjective,
it's up,
there is subjectivity that um,
they,
uh,
they have a lot of discretion.
There is some outlined elements of
protocol,
but there is no,
it is always this or it is always that.
And uh,
you know,
I didn't begrudge them for a period of
ineligibility while you're going through
the process of finding out whether this
is contamination or what have you,
doing any testing.
And that makes sense to me.
That's fine.
I understand that if this guy supposedly
has something in the system,
well let's figure out what it is.
And once we have a better idea,
then we can decide about whether you can
go back into the pool or do this or do
that or if you're going to leverage any
punishments makes sense to me.
But in addition to that,
then tacking on more shit in terms of my
case and I was like,
that's not acceptable.
So we,
we go,
well,
I guess the only thing left to us as to
go to arbitration.
And so my manager spoke with,
um,
when I was working through them to
arbitration and we said,
okay,
well we'll,
what is that going to take?
Well,
that's going to cost more money out of
my pocket.
Um,
you know,
the arbitration process,
these are guys that they're paid by
Usada to do their arbitration.
Like they work for them in a way or
they're not,
they don't work under them directly,
but they are,
they do get paid to be a arbitrator
somehow.
There's some something.
So they get contracted by Usada yes.
And so that was like,
ah,
I don't necessarily feel the most
comfortable with that,
but I can also understand how it's not,
there's probably not an easier way to go
about it,
but okay,
I got it.
Then when we,
uh,
then we get notice back from Usada that
we have to limit the scope of our
argument.
We're like,
Whoa,
what you,
you're gonna tell us what we can and
can't argue in arbitration.
I don't remember what the definitions
were exactly,
but it was like,
you can't,
you know,
you have to keep it within this boundary
and this realm and this.
And I'm like,
well,
you can't fucking try to say the levy
this against me and then you stuff from
my past and then tell me I can't argue
my full case.
So they're limiting the amount that you
could defend yourself as though you're
saying the,
they were limiting the,
um,
the range of argument you could make.
What would the argument be that you
would bring up that they would want to
limit?
Uh,
that's a good question.
I don't know exactly did they define
that?
They know they had definitions in the
emails with,
with back and forth with my manager and
he goes,
we'll fuck we because we could argue
about,
you know,
this is contamination,
um,
and,
and go from there.
But it was something really potentially
limiting,
which was weird about how they put it.
You just don't remember what exactly.
I don't remember all the details,
it's very detail oriented,
it's legal ease and uh,
and then so we get to the point,
it's like,
well fuck,
well this doesn't even look like a very,
you know,
this might not even be a,
a useful way of trying to approach this
thing and it got down to the wire to
where,
and we kept pushing it back and pushing
it back and saying like,
you know,
we can we get an extension and,
and to try and figure out how the hell
do we approach this?
And,
and also like how,
how could we approach without having to
spend money on having lawyers get
involved.
I mean that's the last thing you want to
do is get to litigation or you know,
even arbitration,
it's a legal process.
It's complex and it is,
it's,
there's a lot of lawyers love billable
hours or they do.
And so it gets down to the wire
essentially and we,
I just sit back and I go,
I won't accept any ruling if it's a
punishment at all.
I don't care what they say,
I'll just be like,
Nah,
not I,
I don't.
I'm not going to abide by it.
You can't force me to do shit and I
guess we'll have to cross
position is that if you are accidentally
taking a tainted supplement and also
trace amounts that have absolutely zero
effect on performance,
there's nothing that you're doing by
accidentally taking that that in any way
would help you and that's a fact.
That's a proven fact.
Yes.
So your position is you shouldn't be
punished.
Correct.
Then you're out of the year when once
you.
The time that you've been out.
Here's the thing.
That's enough.
Exactly.
It's one of them.
You don't need to say,
oh,
well if you.
If it took six,
if it took seven months to get the.
The,
the information that you needed the
data,
right?
To then clarify,
okay,
well you're not at fault to then say,
oh,
well we'll suspend you for six months,
but since that six months is already
past,
it's like we didn't suspend you at all.
No.
Motherfucker.
When you look into the haunt a at the
data,
when you go and look at this case,
it says suspended,
which means you punished me,
which means I was guilty in some way.
You said I'm guilty because that's how
you got to punish me.
Right.
It's not under investigation or after
this litigation has exonerated after.
No,
it's just no.
You still love to punishment in there to
say,
look how we caught this guy and we
punished them and I'm like,
I'm not.
I'm not down for that.
And so Hudley enough.
So I was like on aerials or something
like that.
I said,
I,
I won't accept.
I don't care what they say.
I don't care what punishment they try to
levy.
I don't abide by it.
I won't agree to it and I'm done with
them.
And then someone from the arbitrary,
the arbitrators office who we were
dealing with calls us out of the blue
and goes,
so,
so you still sure you don't want to do
this.
I'm like,
well.
And my manager goes,
well they said that we have to limit the
scope of argument to this and this and
we can talk.
And then he goes,
no,
you don't.
You can talk about,
you can,
you can bring any argument you want.
Who is saying this to you?
The arbitrators office.
And
so who would initially come to you and
said the elite,
the scope of your argument Usada.
Okay.
So you saw to,
was attempting to establish some
boundaries for your arguments.
But the people who were the actual
arbitrators said that that's not true.
Right?
That's not the case.
You don't.
It doesn't,
they can't force you to argue in a
certain.
Oh,
okay.
So is it possible that you sought as
lawyers?
We're trying to.
Here's the thing I've found about,
about lawyers,
like,
yeah,
for sure they're necessary and that's
all well and good and you need them.
But there's a reality,
and this is something that I had to deal
with recently in doing something with a
friend through lawyers where they
attached a bunch of shit to this deal
that wasn't supposed to be in there and
he didn't even know it was in there.
And then my lawyer is like,
what the fuck is this?
And so I contact him,
And he's like,
what the fuck is that?
So he contacts his lawyer is what the
fuck is this?
And it turns out this is a common thing
lawyers they want to do with each other.
Yeah.
We put this in to give you leverage.
I don't think you necessarily want that,
but we're looking out for your best
interests.
And so now you have a good negotiation
point.
If you just go in with what you want,
then they're going to ask for more than
that.
And then you're not in a strong position
because you can't ask for more after
you've already established your initial
position.
Makes
everything convoluted there.
Gross.
Yes,
I hear you.
But that's the world we live.
Grandfather was tejas world.
Pretty Pretty Fair lawyer.
He was assistant attorney general,
the state of Washington.
He actually wanted me to get into law of
all things,
but I'm like,
Eh,
I think I'd rather beat out my brain's
yet.
Seems like,
well,
you haven't beaten them out.
Very impressive with your memory.
So we,
uh,
we get to.
My manager comes back and he goes,
hey man,
they just contacted me out of nowhere.
And they're like,
well,
if you want to do this,
you can.
And No,
you can't,
you,
you can make the argument.
There's no limiting in the scope of your
argument or anything.
So then it's like,
well,
yeah,
all right,
I'll go for it.
Went to our least.
Yeah,
because at the very least I thought
maybe I could have some sort of record
down of what we talked about,
what was discussed,
the arguments made.
So in the end,
you know,
no matter what,
how it came out,
I can go here,
here's what's legit,
then you can,
you can make your own decision from
there.
And so we go in,
uh,
I brought my legal team.
They,
he,
they had a,
their lawyer come who was the same guy
we were dealing with throughout the
entire process and,
and they made their argument and we made
ours and you know,
and there,
there are times where I'm sitting back
and I go,
you know,
making,
they're making closing arguments,
the lawyers and I'm just sitting there
listening to the Usada Seigel man,
he's just pushing the,
he's just moving the goal post.
He's a how so?
Well,
it's just taking a certain element and
then trying to,
you know,
you slippery slope arguments and moving
the goal posts on things,
but he's just doing anything he can to
use rhetoric instead of logos at this
point because,
you know,
they're lawyers and they're trying to
make their case and trying to find
impassioned responses when you're saying
this,
you know,
consider the people listening at home.
Don't really know your case,
don't know the scope.
Okay.
So it's like trying to say that,
uh,
you know,
find ways at which to move the goal
posts in terms of.
So what,
like I said to you earlier,
I keep batches of all the supplements
that I take,
especially when I'm in these,
this program and especially after
dealing with the cluster fuck that was
California and it's like,
well I didn't have anything that I could
bring to you that I could fuck,
you know,
so I'm like,
this is never happening again.
So I keep everything they go and they
test stuff and they find it and I kept
notes.
I kept this and it's like,
what more could I have done for you
guys?
Even if it doesn't matter if there's,
let's say what they were all third party
tested as well.
I would still keep batches of the
supplements and one of the stuff I take
third party was the issue then.
Well it's just simply,
it's just they kept trying to say that I
didn't do a good enough job that uh,
did you use the,
uh,
did you see this thing on supplement
form 11?
It's like that came out after the fact
and yes,
I have seen that.
In fact,
I use all the resources that you
provided your global dro,
your other supplement for 11 to check
against ingredient lists,
supplement names,
company names to make sure none of this
shit is on the list so that I don't make
that mistake.
So I use the resources that you give me.
I keep batches
of my supplements so they can be tested
if need be.
I do what's available to keep from any
issues.
And yet they just kept moving the goal
post on that and trying to say,
well,
but you didn't,
uh,
you didn't hire a psychic,
you know,
it's just that kind of shit.
And I'm like,
well,
how,
how can this have been any better?
And not to mention I'm not fighting.
Right.
So at the end of the day,
what were they looking for?
Portration?
Uh,
they wanted to levy a punishment against
me and suspend me for years.
And this is Usada.
Yes.
So you saw to ultimately,
even though they knew that you took a
tainted supplement that had no effect
whatsoever on your performance,
right?
They still wanted to punish you for two
years.
That seems stupid.
That just seemed stupid.
Now let me,
let me read Jeff Novitsky because
Novitsky texted me because I told him
this was going to go down and his take
is a little bit different than yours.
I don't imagine it isn't.
All right.
I'm not surprised that it is.
And I,
uh,
I told you what it was the.
So this is.
I'll just read you what it says.
He said he'll complain about the amount
of time that went by with you saw the
process,
but he notified us of retirement right
after the positive sample was collected
before a positive was announced.
So he was off in the wind for many
months and not communicating with Usada
a big reason the case took so long to
resolve to his positive was from a
tainted supplement,
but he didn't do the number one thing we
advise to use athletes on UFC athletes
on supplements.
He didn't choose a supplement that was
third party certified as a banned
substance free.
Like on it,
supplements are,
there are literally hundreds of
certified supplements out there in
virtually and virtually ensures no
issues to a foreign athlete if they
stick with those.
Uh,
one other point for Barnett when he was
unresponsive to case he missed all of
his deadlines to file for arbitration.
Uh,
he came to the table later and said he
wanted to go to arbitration.
You saw to maiden exclusion and let him,
which ultimately led to his favorable
ruling by arbitrator.
Their reasoning was that they wanted to
rule in favor of fairness to athlete
rules.
Say they didn't have to after time to
file expired.
Well,
but they're saying it ruled favorably
towards you ultimately at the end of the
day.
Yes.
They all live in our favor.
Gobbly goop that the other.
You definitely probably shit.
Like he says that,
oh well he retired and he was in the
wind.
You know what my end,
the wind was.
It wasn't even that long.
I was in Japan for rising with my
athlete.
Alicia Garcia wasn't in the fucking
wind.
Sounds good though.
Even the wind and the wind
fucking you and that motorcycle jacket.
Yeah,
I'm dragging a coffin behind me,
like Django through the Nevada
desert.
Somebody pulls you over,
got eight days growth on your face.
You get some days where you sought out.
We're looking for is broken.
I.
He pissed this cup for me.
I
didn't bring a cup.
Just.
Yeah,
I was in Japan at rising.
You know I wasn't in the wind.
And they in your favor.
The arbitrator arbitrator and what did
they say?
This is the same guy.
The arbitrator is the same guy that put
together is he's an ICARUS.
He produced ICARUS.
The movie on,
on doping.
He is,
he's one of the major figures in terms
of the world of anti-doping.
So it's one of the guys who worked with
Bryan Fogel,
the arbitrator.
Bryan Fogel was the guy who started in
ICARUS.
This guy is a perpetrator for water.
Okay.
I'm actually,
why am I doing this?
Either way you look at Jamie can handle,
but it doesn't matter.
So this guy has the end of the day.
Everything in terms of drug testing,
they really favor.
Yes.
And he said he does it.
He couldn't see any way that I could
have done hardly a better job than I was
meticulous with my record keeping that
uh,
I may,
I did essentially everything I could in
the means of a normal person to do.
How is it resolved at the end?
It was a.
The of reprimand reprimand?
Yeah.
What does that,
what do they do?
Richard H dot Richard Mclaren.
Mclaren chief arbitrator?
Yes.
Okay.
So at the end of the day,
after all this,
they say they gave you a reprimand.
What does that mean?
It just means like don't do that.
Be careful.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's it.
And this took but no punishment.
Right.
And all that two year shift from Usada
was on warranty,
right.
And heavy handed,
heavy handed as hell.
And,
and junior dos Santos went through the
two,
started at at six months.
And then by the time we have both
supplements tested,
then all of a sudden it starts getting
weird.
And you know,
this claim by new whiskey that we were
out of.
No,
we were always in touch.
Novitsky doesn't work for you.
I know.
This is.
So what's Kinda funny is new whiskey is
such a public face on this kind of
thing,
but when it comes to actually dealing
with Usada,
he's all,
he's hands up.
I mean he'll come and he'll,
he'll make sure to put something out
there in any of the sphere.
But in reality he ain't got a fucking
thing to do with any of them.
Okay.
But in his defense,
he's a UFC employee and it's
inappropriate for him to have any
influence whatsoever on the way they
rule things that.
But that's,
that is,
that is that,
I think that's actually the proper thing
for him to do it in a way.
But I mean it's just,
it's a,
it's it.
The presentation is a bit of a misnomer.
I think so.
Well initially he was responsible for
the drug testing.
Now he's,
what is he,
the president of athletes safety and
wellness bucket.
They're running the performance
institute.
Yeah.
I mean,
what they're,
what they're concentrating on now,
but I'm just saying for Jeff and his
shirt off that I think they're
concentrating more on encouraging
fighters to train and,
and,
and fortify their body with nutrition
directly and giving them education
on how to do this and the Jeff is at the
forefront of that stuff and showing them
how to avoid accidentally taking
something and definitely have guess
coming with this is that he is not fully
in the loop with what happened between
me and Usada because he's not involved.
Right.
So some of,
some of what he's saying there is
incorrect and it's not.
I don't blame him because he's not a
part of it.
So is he misinformed at the very least
think that they,
they're not being straightforward with
it sounds to me like they wanted to
punish you badly.
They wanted to punish me badly.
Yeah.
Two years is fucking crazy punishment.
And also when,
when people get to remember when I'm
Nick Diaz was,
uh,
was being interviewed by all these
people.
And then there was that mean lady who
works at Nevada State Athletic
Commission and she was grilling him and
I'm like,
you were talking about pot here.
You crazy lady.
Like,
what in the fuck are you doing?
You're acting like he robbed a bank.
Even if he's not getting in the ring.
Hi.
And leave him alone.
Exactly.
And I think he probably did a few times,
I think.
I think in the Gombe fighting he
might've been highest was like,
oh,
I'm bleeding.
Oh my God,
maybe I should choke him right now.
He didn't give a shit fight.
Jon Jones is going through this right
now.
I don't know where John Jones stands,
but it's been pretty well established
that at the very least,
what the numbers,
if you look at the numbers when he was
tested,
um,
and you know,
I don't know,
a lot of people like to say that he's a
cheater.
There's a lot of this going on right
now.
Look real clear.
The first test was proven that he took
tainted Dick Pills.
Okay.
It was a actually.
So that got brought up to my attention
as part of all this because you know,
you sought a felon,
irrelevant.
The difference between that first one,
let's say,
and I'm not,
I don't know about the second shift with
John,
I don't really follow close on this,
but this came across my plate because he
had,
he was taking like a liquid cialis and
it was from a company that sells sarms
and peptides and all that.
So it was a company that also sells
banned substances.
Right.
And so their argument was that dude,
you're buying or using shit from a place
full of illegal shit.
You're not supposed to take.
Definitely a dumb move.
Definitely.
It means God damn prescription for
Cialis.
Right?
You don't need to take this phone.
I imagine.
Um,
the second one,
what he took,
he had such a minuscule trace amount
that he tested negative.
Then he tested positive,
then he tested negative again.
And this is something that's supposed to
stay in your system for months.
So this is indicative of someone who's
not taking something to get into
performance,
enhance and benefit from it.
But rather someone who had something
that was tainted,
lab technicians are smart on this shit.
Like the guy who saw the results from
the first little batch of supplements we
gave me,
he,
he had seen everything and then some
under
the sun and all different levels and
this guy knew what,
what constituted contamination and it
wasn't.
He could tell,
of course they can tell just by the
numbers.
Look if you'd taken trace amounts of
anything,
it's not gonna do a damn thing to your
body in terms of performance enhancing,
but it is going to show up in these
tests because these tests are incredibly
thorough.
Hey Jamie,
Google what's going on with Jon Jones
case because particularly after this
weekend,
it's very,
very relevant.
You know,
I mean with Brock Lesnar get in there
with DC DC becoming the first light
heavyweight to consecutively hold the
light heavyweight championship and the
heavyweight championship,
you know,
and a spectacular fight by DC.
But Jon Jones is always going to be sure
there you cannot,
you can go on and on about the
extracurricular woes of John Jones.
Sure.
His capabilities as an athlete,
his talent is undeniable,
undeniable.
Look,
whatever the fuck he took Dick Pills,
where as not making them a better
fighter.
He didn't knock dcl because at dick
pills,
that's crazy.
No,
it has to do with great skill and
beautiful left high kick.
That's what it was.
And he recognize that tendency,
you know,
DC knows he has,
uh,
but with this whole Usada process,
it just became an it drug on because w,
you know,
we said to them,
I'm not going to take a punishment.
And they said we won't.
We're not giving you any option on this.
And so that's negotiation.
What happens with.
One of the things that I've talked about
when it comes to police officers is that
when you have police officers and you
know,
people that are trying to arrest it
becomes a game.
And I don't mean a game in terms of it's
bullshit.
I mean it's a game in terms of one
person's trying to win and they're
trying to get people in a restaurant.
And this is why people plant guns and
plant drugs trying to win.
And that's what killed me was that,
to me,
in my opinion,
you sata was trying to win.
It was more important for them to win
than it was for us to have a clean
sport.
This comes back to what we're talking
about earlier when it comes to arguments
and discussions that people oftentimes
are not really searching for the truth.
They just want to be right?
Yes.
And I've had this argument about
bureaucracies in general,
right?
And this goes to,
this isn't just about,
you know,
not Usada and they're bureaucratic
elements tie like the government or
other things.
So you come and you say,
Oh,
you fucked up.
And then the bureaucracies go,
shit,
we didn't fuck up.
And they're going to say we didn't fuck
up to the very.
They'll take that to the very longest
lever until either a they'll scape goat
someone or be they can figure out a way
that they didn't.
Because looking,
making a mistake on a bureaucratic level
makes it seem like,
okay,
well fuck if we.
And here's the thing.
If you saw to says,
oh,
you know,
you're not you,
you didn't,
you're not going to get punished than
two means,
and you'll Romero go,
uh,
why did I get punished?
Or if they,
if you sat down and say,
Oh,
well,
you know,
that was a miss,
that,
that was a mistake.
Well,
if that was a mistake,
well then,
hey,
I got fucked on that mistake.
You don't take care of me.
So no drug testing is bad,
but too much oversight is also bad.
I think that a clean sport is okay and
the idea of the random testing and all
is fine,
but you can't do it at the expense of
the athletes in that we're in the
administration of the testing that
you're trying to blast them.
Like these three Brazilian guys that
just got busted over contamination that
they traced back to a compounding
pharmacy when things.
This is just recent.
So you got three different guys in the
UFC and they were all getting
supplements from a compounding pharmacy
and everything was traced back to it.
It almost seems like you shouldn't take
any fucking supplements.
Well,
that's the other thing is you'll do we,
are,
we not allowed to take anything,
anything at all?
Nothing.
No on it.
What are supplements?
What do they do?
They help your performance.
You know what I mean?
Should you take no performance and
answers?
Should we take nothing?
She just eat food.
I mean,
it's got to be someone out there as
well.
There's food that will enhance your
performance too,
right?
Like kangaroo meat.
The Frank Mir took it,
take some bad kangaroo meat and oh man,
that kangaroo meat.
You get a good pump on that.
First of all,
ain't nobody giving steroids to
Kangaroos.
Kangaroos are fucking everywhere.
Investigation.
Identify as compounding pharmacies.
The source of tainted supplements behind
three positive Almeda and Antonio and
yeah,
a minotauro.
And here's the weird thing.
So it comes all the way down to it and
then they're there.
Highlight on this is.
And you know,
they've,
we put give him a suspension that,
but at the time has already lapsed so
they won't actually have to serve any
time.
It's like,
but you just fucking suspended them
nonetheless.
Yeah.
You didn't have to do that.
So they took seven or eight months or
whatever for this get cleared up and
that's unfortunate.
Junior tested positive for a diuretic.
Is that correct?
That's what it was.
Which hydrochloric or something?
Either diarrhetic,
which is crazy because he's a fucking
heavy one.
Losing any weight junior's not on the
high side of heavyweight.
He's not like a to 65 God.
It's kind of way to make the upper
limit.
Like he's just trying to keep those
wrinkles out of his face.
Just trying to look good.
Maybe just.
Does diarrhetics make you look good?
Look,
I don't know.
I don't think that makes it herself.
It just pulls all the polls.
All the water on bones.
Jones,
keep in mind life is a journey.
Not a race.
God's will for me to be there.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Let's not forget.
I'm still the youngest guy in the top
five of heavyweight and light
everywhere.
Yeah,
he is young.
What does that.
What is unique?
What does that someone's account.
Oh,
is he responding to.
Somebody tweeted that the couple of
hours ago.
It's up to a four year old right now.
He remains a provisional suspension of
wind and the outcome of the situation
with Usada after testing positive for
steroids last July,
following the Naca one of for me,
um,
was it a steroid?
A man?
I couldn't tell you.
John faces up to four years suspension
due to second violation.
Universities anti-doping
Pov is policy,
but obviously young son ever champion.
But obviously first of all when it says
second violation,
the first violation was proven to be
something tainted.
So he's not.
When you say violation,
I want,
I want to hear this guy took steroids.
He took steroids because he was trying
to get a performance enhancing a result
from it.
Suspend that guy.
Don't want to hear,
oh,
he got toothpaste.
It's from China and had fucking
something in it.
You remember that too.
Don't.
You wouldn't have a fucking crazy story
about the toothpaste that had some
poison in it or something that they were
selling in China.
Now what was that?
Some wild shit.
Who was a toothpaste in China?
The poison in it.
Vaguely remembering this.
I just said it just because it sounds
stupid,
but it's really just made it up and all
of a sudden it's true.
It's probably in the back of my memory
somewhere that I just.
I hear what you're saying.
The toothpaste the made in China found
us.
She'll get her fresh.
Sure.
Fresh.
For this,
like some people that don't really
understand English.
Sure.
What?
What does that mean?
I don't know how she'll very good.
Shira.
Shelf fresh.
I think it's a Chinese romanization door
in Maine.
They're trying to kill people in.
Oh yeah.
It's one of those green up there for.
What is it?
What was in it?
Antifreeze.
Okay,
cool.
Cool.
It's main.
Look at how cold it gets up there.
Why wouldn't you need people that know
that they were doing a good job,
but I don't want to.
Teeth falling out.
Freeze and shattering glass.
Little propylene glycol.
Oh,
I'm 100 percent for testing.
I'm 100 percent for them stopping people
from taking performance enhancing drugs,
but this sounds very heavy handed.
It was just an ime.
I had no problem with the system and
then this,
the way it unfolded to me,
it was just like,
this is,
I don't,
I don't need to be fighting multiple
fronts.
What I'm just trying to do everything I
can to stay as in this as an athlete.
Now,
when you first started,
I mean you want to UFC heavyweight title
in 2001 two at 24 years old,
young,
sever.
Um,
when you won,
that meant everybody was on some shit.
It was just,
it was the beginning of the cleanup.
He was everywhere.
And,
and even then going into the Nevada
state athletic commission,
previous to that,
before Zuph have bought the UFC,
the idea of having giant fights in Vegas
was fucking,
oh,
when it was not a possibility,
no,
he's not going to happen.
So,
and even then like,
uh,
the testing back in 2002,
that wasn't official per se,
it was like she was like,
it was esther over him when he fought
Brock Lesnar fucked 2002.
How about when we saw the ream when he
was,
when he was,
when he was ubering,
when he fought Brock Lesnar,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Damn Comic Book Hero.
If I mean there is not a God damn drug
testing agent alive that would have been
grabbing.
He's clearly over $9,000
onto that guy.
Like get the picture of him on the
scale.
Me.
That picture is amazing.
Look at both of them.
Yeah,
they're both boxes,
but that one hold them down.
Everybody would have been like,
hang on,
hang on.
What a needle even.
Could you even get a needle in his vein?
Dude,
he's just pings Benz.
He was so jacked.
This part of me just wishes he would
leave and go to Japan and go right back
to it.
You know,
just fill them up.
I mean,
look,
everybody knew what the fuck it was back
then.
I mean,
it's interesting.
Like brock lesnar being back,
brock lesner is not asking for over him.
Over him was the last guy to really fuck
him up and he wants to fight DC and he
over.
He was just not the same guy anymore.
No,
you're not.
He does not perform at the same level as
he does.
Still.
Very good.
It's still very dangerous.
Here's the thing.
Even when he was a two,
oh,
five pounder,
right.
And he had a tendency to gas up gas out
and get,
you know,
be Chiney to a degree,
but he was always super technical,
highly skilled,
like I don't think you could overeem.
Him and his brother both are actually
very good fighters.
Yeah.
And you know,
their struggles.
I've never been a physical one for the
most part.
I think,
you know,
they've had.
And that's a difficulty that,
that is most common amongst fighters is
the mental game of it.
Well,
we saw that within Ghana this week.
We've seen the fight,
but I heard it was one for the ages.
It was one for the ages.
Someone who just let some lions loosen
that thing and just like,
okay,
let's crank this up a bit.
It was the worst heavyweight fight I've
ever seen.
It was the worst one in mind,
but it came down to,
it came down to the sea.
It was the second lowest output fight
ever.
A demo,
they couldn't even make it the lowest
output fight to be number one.
I didn't even get to number one.
Number one,
they failed that failing.
Jens pulver versus jaw hoke from like a
fucking ufc 13 or some shit.
You know what day that fight was,
but that fight was number one with 23 or
22 strikes landed in three rounds and
this fight was number two with 23
strikes landed.
That's weird,
dude.
It was insane.
And then overeat.
I mean Francis go to Francis and Ganos a
instagram.
He released a statement today and his
statement was essentially that he was
over.
He carried the fear.
He said,
I'm not proud of my last performance.
I have carried my fear from the last
fight to this one.
I completely understand the frustration.
Anger that has caused my fans,
coaches,
teammates,
and family and friends.
Weird that he would have fear from the
last time we cut.
Fucking owned wrestle,
but he didn't know he.
He thought he was the man and then he
got owned and then won't.
But he's letting everyone down again.
All I can do now is proved myself and
make you proud again.
But look at this picture that he puts up
his swinging on him,
him,
him connected,
one punch.
I mean,
that's kind of funny.
It should've been him with his head
down,
Francis in the future.
If you're gonna,
if you're gonna post a humble shot.
Look humble.
There's this is like I'm following him.
I can't say that,
that he doesn't legitimately made.
Maybe he is carrying some kind of fear
from the last fight in terms of losing
the result or is a lot of mind.
Fuck.
That can go into being a fighter.
But uh,
I think with
bounced back,
you've been on both sides and you know,
the first fight back after a kale loss
or after getting dominated,
what is that feeling like?
Oh,
that's a good.
I don't know.
I've been at this shit for so long.
For me it's just like,
all right,
that was then.
This is now don't make the same mistakes
you've experienced
everything you've been submitted,
you've been knocked out,
you've knock guys out,
you submitted guys.
You've won the title.
You beat some of the best guys in the
world.
You've had fantastic performances.
You'd have performances that frustrated
you,
you've experienced at all you've got in
your long career.
I mean,
from being the youngest ever heavyweight
champion of the world ever.
To.
How old are you now?
40,
42,
dude.
You fucking seen it all.
You've literally seen it all.
How long do you think you can do?
Uh,
I don't know,
but I'm planning to run it out.
You do also have a lot more in Japan,
bro.
Keep going.
I also have this bad habit that need
cash for 55 Pontiac's don't get built
and put into a 75 trans ams firebirds
for free.
Well,
sometimes they do.
If you have the time,
that's anything.
How are you going to work on your car
when you're off all over the world doing
all this shit,
right?
Doing seminars and doing pro wrestling
commentary.
All my fighters,
I had two guys just fight,
uh,
last Friday at cxf in Burbank.
One of them defended his title,
Aga,
Brian,
the other ones.
Show him a photo on his fight.
And for people who don't know,
that's not lucrative to train fighters.
I mean at the very highest level,
it's barely lucrative.
Barely.
Yeah.
I'm not.
This isn't a money thing.
This is a passion project training guys
out of with Jim at the UFC gym in La
Mirada,
let's use it for a fantastic feat.
And we get use of all 55,000
square feet.
Oh,
that's nice.
We also work a lot with,
uh,
Chad George has a gym called Cmma and
we'll send them.
We'll go down there to.
Nice was good comradery between Marotta.
Where's that at?
Like Northern Orange County.
Okay.
I would say.
Yeah.
Is it like,
um,
what's it like northern orange?
It was the border of Orange County where
it's like at that border it's either
southern,
most la county or northern most orange
county.
It's that kind of thing.
Yeah,
those UFC gyms are fucking bad ass.
They are great job.
Super Nice.
And plus they've been an opportunity for
fighters.
I think cub and bisping also have stakes
in some.
Cj does is.
Well I believe Frankie Edgar does.
Frankie has one in Tom's.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's quite a few of them now.
I mean they're all over the place.
If you look for a place to hit the heavy
bag and workout and lift weights and
martial arts classes,
cages and maths and all that and so we
use those facilities.
They've been really great to us and
yeah,
with these,
these kids that I work with and they are
pretty much kids.
It's just about trying to help people
achieve work towards the things that
they want as an athlete,
but also they're good people that I want
to see them make the most out of their
life,
you know,
so I'm trying to be a person that can be
a positive influence in terms of
bringing philosophy and ethics to their
life and helping them be good people and
to pass that kind of shit on b,
the ripple in the water that the drop in
the water that sends ripples out,
that makes a positive effect on other
folks.
Throw you a poet.
What the fuck?
No Bro.
Just sometimes it just comes to me,
man.
You should put that on an instagram
picture and show your butt because
that's where a lot of those girls do
that,
but,
and then they have like something about,
you know,
don't like net negativity into your life
because the ripples of that negativity
can infect the people around you and you
don't want that stay positive.
Look on my ass.
Fucking pull up on them on these.
Look at peach.
Yeah.
Um,
I think that UFC gym is a brilliant
thing to brilliant move because if I'm
like,
if I see 24 hour fitness and it's right
next to the UFC gym,
like,
oh,
fucking heavy bags.
Everything.
What the fights are on TV.
Yes.
Put that on.
They also,
uh,
at least the one in La Mirada has like a
whole little section that has astroturf
down and all that.
Little with ladders that have been
painted into it so he can do foot
drills.
Oh,
nice.
They've got a sleds and tires and shit.
You mean.
So you can do other nonconventional
workouts,
kettlebells.
So they have it really like a real
strength and condition.
Yes.
I mean,
you can do really anything.
They have a whole setup of trx is and
shit like that shit.
Yeah,
that's bad ass.
Yeah.
That's,
I mean that's what you want from a gym
when you go to a lot of gyms,
they just don't have that kind of stuff.
You know,
they have your standard stuff,
you know,
machines and shake,
you could lift with.
It's just not,
not quite good enough
that I agree.
And so this gives you that,
that full spectrum to,
to work in whatever ways you want to
just about.
Would you be interested in owning your
own gym?
Sometimes I think about it.
I do.
I wouldn't mind having it,
having
my own gym,
but it's just such a,
I don't want to,
burden isn't the right word,
but there's just a lot of responsibility
that comes with it,
you know,
the overhead of having a place and
creating a program,
uh,
and having people manage and run those
programs.
And with me being as busy as I am,
um,
I wouldn't want to do anything half ass
and I also don't want to commit to
something and then not be able to put
into it what I think is necessary.
You obviously love teaching.
I do.
I do love to teach.
Yeah.
I like,
for me,
it was such a big thing in my life,
the people,
not just in terms of athletics,
but the people mentored
me and helped to mold and shape me and
help give me the tools and sometimes a
kick in the ass as needed to,
to move me along in life to get me to
where I am today,
to give me not just in terms of what,
what you would argue for is successful
or not,
but just to be the person that I am.
And while far from perfect,
uh,
you know,
I can't,
I can't think about exchanging bad
moments for different moments in my
life.
For the fear of that.
I wouldn't be who I am today.
You know,
a Nietzsche talks about eternal
recurrence.
And one of the idea of that is that,
um,
and your loneliest,
loneliest,
have a demon showed up and it said,
well,
you're going to live your life in every
way as you ever have in every single
aspect of it.
It's like,
well,
you have to have to be okay with that.
You have to live a life that,
that,
that's,
that's reasonable,
that you would be fine with doing it all
over again.
Doing it all over again.
If you're going to become,
if you're going to be specific
specificity,
better like pushing a rock up a hill,
right?
Whatever mistakes you've made,
they have made you who you are right
now.
Correct.
As long as it's not catastrophic to the
point where you've caused a loss of life
or someone's devastated and destroyed
someone else's life,
you hope not.
I hope not.
I mean,
I know it's interesting thing like that.
There's the concept of reincarnation.
There's many concepts with one of them
is the,
one of the most,
a haunting for some people is that you
will live your life over again.
Exactly the same way until you get it
right.
I actually heard Leo Gracie talking
about this once,
that everything in your life,
every mistake,
every choice you make,
if you do not do the correct thing,
he believed that you would have to come
back again and do it all over again.
Exactly the same way.
And this is his philosophy,
the way he lived his life.
That's terrifying for people.
This idea that somehow or another you're
going almost like you're going to repeat
high school.
Sure you don't put.
But here's how brutal,
brutal period of my life and my mind to.
But here's my question.
I think everybody's and the people who
it wasn't brutal for those fucking
people turn up,
be losers,
stories of that.
The fucking homecoming king in this.
I mean,
that's like a fucking billy Joel Song.
Yeah,
the king and the queen of the Prom,
you know,
that's a scenes from an Italian
restaurant that's,
that's literally the,
the premise of that song.
I think it was,
uh,
it was,
um,
a immortal song too.
Norway brand new and not with the
populist and the king and the queen of
the prom running around with the top
down and the radio on.
Nobody looked any finer who is more of a
hit at the parkway diner and we never
knew we could walk more than that.
I live.
Remember that I.
I don't know it as well as you do.
It's a good song.
The idea of living your life over again
is terrifying for people though.
The dying alone,
but the living over and over and over
again for a finisher,
but,
but why is that?
When living right now,
it's fine for most of us.
I mean,
unless you're depressed,
unless you depressing life to wreck
living right now it's like,
okay,
I'm alive.
I'm here,
I'm doing it.
Sure.
Why scared to do it over and over and
over.
We had forever.
It's a strange thing,
like there's something like the futility
of it all.
The idea that this is just a repeating
cycle that's going to haunt you forever.
Well,
that would in the idea that there would
be nothing that you could do to make any
effect to it.
I mean to Mifa even,
even still,
like I couldn't,
me personally,
I couldn't think of something that in
terms of like a,
I want to do something that as a mental
idea,
as a,
as a mind game,
that if I lived my life in a way that I
could be okay with doing it all over
again.
Just exactly the same way.
And here's the other thing.
Would you know that it's gonna happen
like that?
How could you.
Well,
there was a,
I got,
I,
I wish I could remember who it was.
There was this philosopher who was
saying that if you were given the
ability to absolutely and utterly
control your dreams and all aspects and
elements of it.
And so at first most people would,
would go to sleep and they would turn it
into every fucking wonderful thing
they've ever wanted.
They would just be the ultimate winner
at everything all the time,
always.
And then they would get tired of that
and then they would create chaos and
catastrophe in,
in,
you know,
make probably make everything is
horrible for themselves and they could
possibly do.
And as they're going through these
cycles,
ultimately the one thing that you're
going to end up wanting in the end is
that you just don't know what's going to
happen at all.
Find by knowing everything prior to it
occurring,
it takes the want to experience it away.
Cormac McCarthy wrote a,
um,
how many people,
if they knew the path of their lives,
which still choose to live it,
woo.
Well,
there isn't that ultimately expressed by
fighting,
like fighting is the ultimate expression
of that.
Because when you step into that cage of
it's just you and you're looking at
another guy who's a,
a legitimate top flight mixed martial
artists and you really don't know.
I have a theory about fighting and that
fighting is actually a,
not the only,
but a great conduit into what I think of
as the highest point of,
of being as a human being.
That you can enter into this state,
that it's not a place that you can
exist.
That all the time,
like it's just not possible.
But when you breach it,
it is.
If you are so alive and you were at
your,
the peak of being at that moment,
and even though it is,
it is brought on through through being
in the the intensity and the stress of
combat,
it's as every aspect of your being is
charged in electric,
in and living and being,
but it's not a place that you could be
at all the time.
You would just be a maniac,
right?
It's not a place that human beings can
exist in for more than maybe short
periods of time.
Hm.
Well,
your senses have to be insanely
heightened.
Your,
your you.
The consequences of your actions are
grave.
The only thing that really is elevated
passed out as war and one of the things
that you find about war and Sebastian
younger wrote about this in his book,
tribe,
is that the people that experienced it
have an incredibly difficult time
adjusting to regular life.
Sure,
and they really miss it and want to go
back to it because they never felt more.
I believe that that war is a similar
place.
I think that when you are faced with
death that that is a,
a conduit to bringing you towards that
highest point of,
of being.
And uh,
yeah,
I suppose it's like that once you get
past that point of view,
there is no fear at that level either.
It is just an,
it is a way.
It's just an existence you don't
consider.
You don't think,
you don't think something isn't this or
that.
It just is and it's a place that you
can't be forever,
wouldn't,
it doesn't work that way.
But when you've been there and here just
out here dealing with petty again,
Internet trolls and dumb shit and people
doing stuff that,
that cut their nose to spite their face
and undermining this and you know,
the fabric of our relationships for no
good reason.
It's,
it's tough to,
to sit in,
exist in this and go fuck,
you know,
I how,
how do you get back to that other thing,
this,
this state of purity,
this existence of where these,
none of those things matter anymore.
I don't know if you can,
I mean you,
you might have.
I mean,
look,
we have a certain amount of time on
this,
on this planet,
in this life,
right?
You have a 100 years.
If everything goes great,
you can't really expect to just live in
that.
That perfect state of both chaos and and
chaos and I guess being in the moment
there's something about something that's
dangerous and intense and overwhelmingly
filled with anticipation beforehand and
the preparation is all consuming.
There's very few things in life that are
the like these big moments like a person
stepping into a cage for a fight and the
consequences are so grave.
It just for your emotions,
for your physical health,
this is.
There's really nothing like it is really
the,
the to expect that you would find
something else similar in life and to be
able to achieve a similar state.
Outside of that it's.
I don't.
I don't think you ever will because I
feel like part of what makes what you do
and what all fighters do so intense and
so incredibly enjoyable to watch is that
we all know how much is on the line.
I think.
I believe I'm 100 percent in agreement
with you there and I think race car
drivers and fighter pilots.
I think people like that also likely
experienced that state of being as well.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Fighter pilots.
It has to be fighter pilots.
Apparently.
I was reading some story about this,
about wife swapping.
They're like they,
they,
uh,
they're more inclined to have
polyamorous relationships.
Really.
Yeah.
And then the wife swap because the idea
was that they know that their life
easily could be wiped out any day at any
time.
And the people they care about the most,
their wife or their girlfriend,
that they want other people to love them
because they might not be.
They're interesting and that they would
want the people they care about the
most.
I love them because they're thinking in
a altruistic fashion of doing what they
can,
I suppose to help this person that they
care so much about continuing to find
joy in their life.
Yeah.
Because of their,
their realization that what joy they may
be able to derive from them specifically
is is always on a thin line of not being
there anymore.
That's fucking intense.
The love someone so much.
You want other people to fuck them
because how do I get on that list?
Well,
it's probably already on there.
Just got to ask.
I suppose
the which comes back to the one thing
that is I think poison in life,
which is to live a dual life.
Grieve a boring no risk,
10 or run,
no thrills,
no challenge,
no growth,
no knowledge,
no learning.
Just this stagnant bullshit life that is
so prevalent in our society.
I think it's one of the main problems
with our world is that we have set up
these really safe cities and safe
societies and cultures,
which is wonderful.
It's great,
but also we.
We haven't given people the discipline
or the structure or the.
The just the framework for living a life
that's going to satisfy your needs in
terms of your biological needs.
Yes.
Psychological and people start
determining that totally inane things
are what their needs are.
They're difficult to acquire,
right?
You think of Ferrari's going to make you
happy because a Ferrari is hard to get.
Sure.
Look at it like how much do you cost?
If I just had that man,
I'd be bawling.
I'd be driving around.
So Rad.
I'd be bawling.
But then you get that Ferrari.
You like.
This is just a car.
Yeah,
like unless you just really love cars
like you could love,
you know your firebird and you
appreciate it from a mechanical
standpoint.
You want to step back and look at it.
It's enjoyable,
but if you think that the fucking things
going to make you happy,
you're crazy.
B,
then me being happy with who I am as a
person and the life that I'm living,
the firebird can't do,
can't do that.
There is no item.
You know,
I have to sit back and all the time and
try to think for myself that
you,
you've,
I,
I love my library,
that I have all the books within it.
I love the cars that I have.
I love the relationships that I have,
but instead of the relationship,
but just the things and it's like these
are all great things,
but if I don't have them,
I'm still me.
I still have everything that I need in
this world.
I don't like to think about them being
lost,
destroyed.
I certainly hit the idea of it being
destroyed because even if it wasn't in
my hands,
I'd like them to still exist for others,
but without them.
I'm no different than who I am now and I
guess that's kind of a thinking of like
the Stoics,
but you've been more defined by your
accomplishments in your thinking and
your philosophy and there's lots of
things that people
obviously they couldn't know about me
because it's not the kind of thing that
is just my who I am.
Right?
And,
and I don't need someone to know whether
or not I'm smart or whether or not I
know this or whether or not I can do
that.
It's like I'll do it when I need to do
it and I,
I have to try and look to see that I
have my own inner peace is based on my
own self knowledge and knowledge also
that I am lacking,
that I can be better,
that I,
if I want to,
I can choose to in those days that I
don't.
It was a choice not to be better.
It wasn't that I couldn't because even
going and failing like we talked about
before is a worthwhile endeavor because
it will move you towards either a
eventually getting there or be that it's
not something that's going to be yours,
but you know what it is and you know
what it takes to get there and that's a
different perspective altogether and
that is where I feel like that's where I
can be okay in this world and deal in.
There's all kinds of things that you can
draw your focus and really eat at you
and bother you and you're giving weight
to these things and allowing them to
have an effect on you and that's
natural.
That's a normal thing and it's easy to
fall into,
but if you can be okay with.
All right,
if all I'm left with is just me and what
I have,
if I no longer have anything,
no,
no more luxuries,
no more this,
no more that.
Can you be okay with that?
Do you know what kind of life would you
make of this?
And I like to think the same one I have
now.
You can pick me up here,
take all my shit away,
throw me some other part of the world,
the third world country,
and it will be jarring.
It will be difficult and there will be
some lament of,
but I will continue to be who I am.
I will see what is necessary to to
communicate with others and to continue
to propagate this that I'm trying to
create in me.
Yeah.
I think we're all trying to navigate
this really incredibly difficult thing,
which is your just your life.
You're the emotions,
the,
your goals,
your tasks,
your relationships,
your,
your dreams and aspirations.
All these things are just so complicated
in the whole idea of not knowing what
the future holds is stressful,
but it's also incredibly rewarding when
things work out well and even when they
don't work out well.
What's rewarding about that?
As you get the gift of knowing that you
fucked up and you get the gift of the
feeling of fucking up and the horrible,
just the feeling of failure and to
understand that that's fuel for you to
regroup,
repackage your fucking thoughts and and
now move forward with the knowledge of
the mistakes that you've made and you're
going to be a better person.
How can you fuck up if you don't do
anything?
If you don't ever do it,
you don't just sit back and you try to
lead the simplest,
safest version of a life.
It's not a life on the line and it's not
a life I can really imagine that anyone
can really be truly fulfilled living and
you know,
things are ultimately incredibly soft on
us.
I mean,
we have pressures in other ways,
but ultimately most of us are living
quite comfortable lives with no
immediate dangers and no,
no real impetus to put stress on
ourselves where it doesn't exist at
times because let's just say you want to
learn new language.
There's agitation in terms of,
of forcing you to have to endure
something.
There's some suffering in that and you
know,
I believe in the Nietzschean concept of
suffering creates growth.
You know,
life is suffering.
Suffering doesn't have to be
catastrophic.
It doesn't have to be this sort of thing
that is going to debilitate you,
but that suffering is needed for you to
continue to become better,
for sure.
Everything with exercise,
with learning,
with everything,
with even relationships,
learning in relationships that all those
uncomfortable feelings are how you
learn.
Yes.
Learning relationships.
I,
I've always said to two friends of mine,
you know,
the first time they have like a big blow
out with something called me up and I'll
fuck,
you know,
so and so said this and I don't know how
their Dick ended up there and all this
stuff.
Look ultimately,
yeah.
No one wants to get into a row with
someone,
especially someone that you really care
about,
but if,
if this is an important relationship,
the only way it becomes a relationship
that has that deeper lasting meaning and
that really has any real depth to it at
all,
is what you do when you guys are faced
with adversity that shows you what
relationship you have.
Because when things are fun and easy,
anybody can be a part of it,
right?
We're all just,
you know,
humping and drinking and going out and
that's great.
Fucking wonderful.
But when someone good,
once it's pretty,
it's not bad as a single guy,
I'm constantly looking for that
opportunity.
But ladies,
if you live in a hump and drink and
drink and drink and hump mainly whiskey
in coffee,
but drinking it,
hopping and muscle cars,
if you're into that,
uh,
but when you get into these,
all of a sudden adversity comes across
your doorstep.
How you'd handle that.
And you know,
whether you're the person who brought it
or you're the person who's in enduring
it from the other side.
And if you haven't experienced that in
your life and also experience it in a
relationship,
man,
you might not be ready.
That's true.
Might not have the tools you need.
You need to do.
That's difficult,
right?
It gives you the tools to navigate
difficult situations and the other
aspects of your life.
Agreed.
Yeah.
It is the.
The stresses of having to to deal with a
problem and how you handle that problem
because there will never be any shortage
of problems,
of difficulties from,
from great too small and you,
your way of,
of mitigating those problems and dealing
with them is,
is so important.
It's.
It determines how it works out for you.
That's right.
Bitches.
Josh Barnett dropping knowledge like
advertised.
Let's wrap this up.
Josh.
He's a man.
We got to do this more often.
We do it like once a year now.
I would love to come in more often.
I,
I especially would love to even at some
point like when you've got Brett in here
and you've got Jordan and all that.
I'm just gonna sit in,
talk on philosophy and something like
that.
I love the shit out of them.
Do it.
Let's do it,
Josh Barnett,
ladies.
Gentlemen.
Bye everybody.